nous rapportons la merci donc nous
pouvons reprendre nos auditions 7la et
celle là est consacrée à la
communication élément déterminant en
période de crise
nous aurons l'occasion d'en parler tout
au long de cette matinée les excuses du
président alain milon président de la
commission des affaires sociales et
président de la commission denquête il
est retenu sur son département c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'animerai ce débat
en tant que vice président alors ce
matin nous allons donc entendre madame
si bête ndiaye ancien porte parole du
gouvernement
merci madame et yves sciama sciamma
président de l'association des
journalistes scientifiques de la presse
d'information pour l'information des
commissaires je me dois d'indiquer que
le bureau avait souhaité qu'on vient
cette audition la direction de la
communication de santé publique france
afin de mieux comprendre bien sûr
comment se déroulait le continuum entre
l'épidémiologie l'analyse scientifique
et la production des messages à
destination du grand public
il s'est avéré que personne n'était
véritablement chargée de ces questions
au sein de santé publique france au
démarrage de la crise notamment l'
agence nous a cependant indiqué que
l'ensemble des messages était discuté
avec le service d'information du
gouvernement
vous aurez l'occasion madame de nous
préciser tout cela nous ne sommes pas
ici pour faire un florilège de
déclarations qui de le contexte actuel
pourrait apparaître incongru nous sommes
ici pour comprendre comprendre le
processus de prêt de production de ces
déclarations en fonction bien sûr de
l'évolution de la maladie et ce que nous
attendons de vous madame indien c'est
non pas l'impact ou l'adéquation de la
situation ce que nous entendrons de
monsieur schiappa mais véritablement
qu'elle était et la stratégie
s'agissant d'un virus inconnu la
connaissance a bien sûr et évolutive et
le discours officiel a dû s'adapter
nous avons eu parfois le sentiment non
seulement qu'il a envoyé des signaux
contradictoires ou flottants mais aussi
qu'il s'adaptait aux capacités
disponibles notamment un équipement de
protection
il faudra répondre à ces questions
madame si la communication
gouvernementale a pu apparaître
flottante comme je le disais elle
intervenait dans un climat général de
grands désordres du fait notamment des
désaccords publics entre les
scientifiques et du foisonnement d
expression des uns et des autres sur les
plateaux de télévision
je vous me demanderais de d'intervenir
par des propos liminaires 5 6 minutes
chacun si vous en êtes d'accord c'est
comme ça que nous procédons de cette
commission denquête ensuite ce sont les
les trois rapporteurs qui poseront
directement les questions vous y
répondre et ensuite on globalise les
questions de nos commissaires cette
audition doit durer jusqu'à non madonna
toute la matinée 1 nous avons la matinée
c'est parfait c'est parfait nous avons
la matinée donc on aura le temps de
répondre à tout cela alors conformément
à la procédure des commissions d enquête
je dois vous rappeler que tout
témoignage mensonger et susceptible
d'une amende pouvant aller jusqu'à 75
mille euros et même d'une peine de
prison pouvant aller jusque 5 ans et je
vais vous demander de prêter serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité levé la
main droite et deal je le jure je le
jure je le jure
si ce seuil est en fait madame je vous
cède la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs
je voudrais d'abord évidemment vous
remercier pour l'opportunité que vous me
donnez de venir ici éclairé au fond la
représentation nationale sur la
communication mise en oeuvre par le
gouvernement à l'occasion de la terrible
crise sanitaire que nous avons vécue et
que malheureusement force est de le
constater on continuons à vivre
ayant quitté le gouvernement le 3
juillet dernier je ne serait évidemment
pas en capacité de m'exprimer je ne
serai évidemment capacité de réexprimer
que sur la période où j'ai été en
fonction
quant à l'organisation de la
communication institutionnelle et
politique du gouvernement
cette crise vous le savez a était inédit
tant par sa violence son ampleur que par
sa durée et nous partageons sans doute
tous elle marquera durablement notre
pays et en tant que j'allais dire
personne très citoyenne très attaché au
service public à l'état à son
fonctionnement j'espère que elle
permettra d'améliorer nos capacités de
gestion de situations de crises
complexes
je voudrais dans ce propos introductif
profiter du temps qui m'est imparti pour
vous expliquer peut-être de manière
rapide
quel est le rôle exact du porte parole
du gouvernement et celui que j'ai tenus
au cours de ses premiers mois de crise
conformément à un décret d'attribution
qui est assez peu varié depuis la
création du poste à la fin des années 60
le porte parole du gouvernement est
chargé de deux missions principales
il doit chaque semaine rendre compte des
travaux du conseil des ministres et plus
généralement exercer une mission
d'information sur les activités du
gouvernement dans ce cadre en tant que
porte parole du gouvernement nous
participons en tant que de besoin aux
réunions d'arbitrage interministériel
ces fameuses rim que vous connaissez et
nous sommes supposés recevoir de la part
de nos collègues ministres toutes
informations qui puissent contribuer à
exercer cette mission d'information ce
qui nous permet ce faisant de porter la
voix du gouvernement sur l'ensemble de
ses domaines d'action et des sujets
d'actualité
en appui de nos collègues ministres
évidemment pour être plus précise à
l'occasion de la crise du coronavirus
j'ai donc participé à la quasi totalité
des conseils de défense à vocation
sanitaire et à de nombreuses réunions
animées notamment par le premier
ministre ou le président de la
république avec les élus locaux les
parlements de faire les organisations
syndicales et patronales ainsi que les
fédérations professionnelles
j'en oublie sans doute grâce à la
participation que j'ai eu assez
différentes réunions
grâce aux informations communiquées par
mes collègues ministres en charge de la
gestion j'allais dire opérationnelle de
la crise j'ai pu contribuer à expliciter
l'action du gouvernement
la stratégie qui était la nôtre les
évolutions de cette stratégie
ces adaptations au fur et à mesure de
l'acquisition de connaissances et je
l'espère ainsi contribuer à éclairer nos
concitoyens dans ma mission j'ai bien
sûr pu disposer du service d'information
du gouvernement le sgg dont je veux
profiter de ce moment pour saluer le
professionnalisme la réactivité et la
disponibilité pour être très concrètes
cette mise à disposition du sg m'a
permis de bénéficier de moyens
techniques logistiques par exemple pour
l'enregistrement de vidéos à caractère
pédagogique pour les réseaux sociaux
mais également de bénéficier de
l'analyse de l'état de l'opinion qui
nous a permis d'adapter notre stratégie
de communication ou encore d' analyses
relatives aux réseaux sociaux en
particulier sur le sujet très important
je crois des fakes news mais j'imagine
qu'on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
au cours de nos échanges disposant de
ces analyses de ces comptes rendus et
compte tenu de l'expérience
professionnelle qui était la mienne
antérieurement tant que conseillère
communications
j'ai eu l'occasion de donner des avis
des conseils notamment au cabinet du
premier ministre sur la stratégie de
communication institutionnelle qui
étaient préconisées par le sg je
voudrais terminer mon propos en vous
disant qu'au fond depuis la fin des
années 60 le rôle du porte parole du
gouvernement quelle que soit la manière
dont les premiers ministres ont pu
organisé cette fonction à l'intérieur de
leur équipe gouvernementale ses missions
assez peu changé le contexte dans lequel
elles s'exercent à lui en revanche
radicalement changé l'environnement
médiatique s'est considérablement
enrichi en particulier avec la création
des chaînes d'information continue et
dans le même temps je crois que
l'exigence de transparence
d'horizontalité de nos concitoyens
vis-à-vis de la prise de décision
publique s'est largement accrue nous
avons connu dans le même temps
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux en
particulier de twitter et de facebook
qui a largement aussi bouleversé la
donne désormais au fond chacun peut être
vecteur d'information sans pour autant
répondre aux impératifs déontologiques
de la profession de journaliste
chacun peut donner son avis et on
considère au fond que tous se valent
chacun donne à chaque instant son
opinion et chacun entend disposer d'une
information qui soit instantanée et d'un
commentaire de cette information qui
soit immédiat sans le recul qui parfois
est nécessaire ceci étant posé parce que
je veux pas être beaucoup plus longue
je conclurai en vous dira qu'à titre
personnel je retiens de cette période
l'extraordinaire mobilisation des
français de nos compatriotes des
services publics qui ont tenu debout
dans un moment extrêmement compliqué et
de la capacité d'adaptation de notre
pays a eu face à une crise protéiforme
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs ce que je
voulais évoquer avec vous en
introduction de cette table ronde je
suis évidemment à votre disposition pour
répondre à toutes vos questions
merci monsieur yves sciama
bonjour mesdames et messieurs je
remercie les membres de la commission de
m'avoir fait l'honneur de m'inviter et
n'ayant pas la notoriété d'un certain
nombre de mes prédécesseurs je me
présente brièvement je suis journaliste
scientifique indépendant mon principal
employeur et le magazine science et vie
mais j'écris également dans le quotidien
le monde où la revue internationale
sarrians la santé faisant partie de mes
spécialités j'ai écrit plusieurs
articles sur la crise du coc vide
notamment durant le mois d'avril où les
incertitudes étaient particulièrement
grande je suis depuis trois ans le
président de la js pays l'association
qui en france regroupe les journalistes
scientifiques
il faut comprendre par là que nous
sommes journées scientifiques comme
d'autres sont journalistes économiques
sportifs ou politiques
nous ne sommes pas des scientifiques qui
ferait du journalisme temps en temps
mais des journalistes professionnels qui
couvre la science
notre association compte près de 300
membres qui travaillent aussi bien pour
des médias spécifiquement scientifique
que pour des quotidiens des radios et
des télévisions
cette crise sanitaire a été un séisme
pour notre profession car nous faisons
tous le constat d'un véritable fiasco en
matière d'information et de
communication nous constatons tous dans
le courrier de nos lecteurs sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans notre vie
quotidienne
la montée d'une défiance généralisée
notamment vis-à-vis des médias de la
science et de ses institutions pour ne
rien dire du politique
nous voyons se propager y compris dans
des milieux sociaux et éduquer
habituellement éclairer un flux
ininterrompu de fausses informations
dont beaucoup sont même rocambolesque
nous voyons apparaître de prétendus
experts et notamment des médecins qui
défendent avec aplomb des points de vue
à mille lieues de ce que dit la science
et qui trouvent facilement des
auditoires important et enfin nous
percevons un grand désarroi en
particulier parmi nos concitoyens les
plus raisonnables
devant l'état chaotique et souvent
violents de l'information qu'ils
reçoivent sur la pandémie
ce désastre nous interpelle d'autant
plus qu'il ya une réelle soif de
connaissance d'informations et de séance
dans le public et que cette pandémie en
faisant surgir un ennemi commun
microbien de surcroît aurait peut-être
pu permettre à notre pays de faire bloc
et de se convaincre de la valeur d'au
moins une partie de ses élites or c'est
l'inversé qui s'est produit
comme toute crise de communication
sanitaire celle que nous vivons résulte
des actions de trois parties le monde
médical
le monde politique et les médias qui ont
tous leur part de responsabilité je vais
passer en revue très rapidement le
principal problème côté médical a été
l'irruption du professeur raoul tu qui
dès le début de la pandémie a promu
agressivement sur la base de ses seules
convictions un traitement initialement
non prouvées qui a continué à le faire
quand les preuves de son inefficacité
ont été fournies ce problème aurait sans
doute pu être limitée à l'apparition
d'un pseudo traitement miracle comme il
en surgit dans toutes les épidémies
si les autorités scientifiques et
médicales étaient intervenus fermement
dès le début pour arrêter cette fuite en
avant
mais l'institution médicale et je pense
notamment à l' agence du médicament à
l'ordre des médecins osaka aide aux
académies à la haute autorité de santé
est restée silencieuse et ceci a ouvert
la boîte de pandore et en nombre
croissant de médecins souvent issus des
sommets de l'institution se sont sentis
autorisés à prendre la parole et donner
des avis sur la base de leur seule
conviction
cette attitude s'est ensuite propagé au
point qu'il est devenu admissible dans
la profession médicale de dénigrer les
responsables de santé publique et les
mesures qu'ils prouvent qu'ils
préconisent ce qui a rendu inaudible et
nombreux excellents médecins qui
s'expriment sur la base des études
existantes et cette situation perdure
actuellement ce dysfonctionnement des
institutions médicales a été aggravée
par l'attitude du monde politique
d'une part il ya eu la désastreuse
affaire du mensonge sur les masques qui
a durablement discrédité la parole
gouvernementale
mais même une fois que les
recommandations du ministère de la santé
sont devenus conforme à l'état du savoir
il ya eu un soutien du professeur raoul
tu puissant de l'ensemble de l'échiquier
politique enfin pour certaines personnes
jusqu'à l'actuel président qui est allé
lui rendre visite
ces soutiens aux crédibiliser le
dénigrement de l'institution médicale et
renforcé l'idée que toutes les opinions
sont légitimement santé publique et que
tout le monde est compétent pour en
parler tout ceci a été aggravée par les
réseaux sociaux enfin les médias ont eu
leur part de responsabilité également
mais comprenez que pour un journaliste
de moins de 30 ans sans expérience des
questions médicales débordées multitâche
surtout s'il travaille sur un média
formaté par la recherche de l'audience
et du buzz une telle confusion n'est ce
pas identifier les bons messages et les
bons interlocuteurs
dans l'ensemble les journées
scientifiques de ce pays ont quand même
remarquablement couvert la maladie
relisez les pages science du monde et du
figaro les magazines scientifiques
écouter les émissions telles que la
méthode scientifique vous y trouverez
très peu d'erreurs même au moment où les
incertitudes étaient les plus grandes
mais par contre les médias qui n'avaient
pas de journalistes spécialisés et
particulièrement les télévision
d'information continue donc pas su
résister à la tentation du buzz et
continue à vouloir faire de l'audience à
tout prix véhicules ont encore
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui de
manière acritique les messages
scientifique erronées voire absurde et
la défiance à l'égard de l'institution
médicale se met par les personnes
qu'elles invitent ce qui est à mes yeux
une faute éthique
je note également que certains médias
disposant de service science compétents
ont néanmoins massivement promu dans
leurs pages opinions ou débat des points
de vue scientifique infondées j'aimerais
conclure sur un point il ya dans
l'actuel projet de loi sur la
programmation de la recherche
l'idée de mettre sur pied une maison de
la science et des médias dont l'objectif
serait d'améliorer le traitement
médiatique de la science et ce en
fournissant sur le modèle du serial ce
média center britannique des contenus
scientifiques tout préparés aux médias
des interviews déjà réalisé et c'est
pour pallier à leur illettrisme
scientifique je pense qu'une telle
institution serait perçue par le public
comme une tentative de promouvoir une
science officielle et aggraverait la
déférence aussi bien vis-à-vis des
médias que de la production scientifique
à mes yeux
l'actuelle crise appelle un réarmement
scientifique des médias qui doivent
enfin investir ce champ est essentielle
qu'est la science ce qui passe par le
recrutement de journalistes spécialisés
mais aussi par le fait de donner à ces
journalistes spécialisés davantage de
poids face au service politique et
économique
cela améliorerait grandement
l'information sur cette épidémie
mais plus généralement l'information sur
les grands enjeux de notre époque le
climat l'énergie l'agriculture qui ont
tous une forte composante scientifique
je vous remercie merci donc vous avez
tenus dans vos propos liminaire dans le
temps merci nous commençons par bernard
sylvie vermeillet aller sylvie
vermeillet ensuite bernard jomier et
catherine de roche alors sylvie
vermeillet madame le rapport merci
monsieur le président je vais poser une
question à chacun madame doyer sur sur
la communication du gouvernement
je crois que je vais pas revenir sur la
question des masques sûrement que mes
collègues le feront au delà de ce qui
pouvait se passer dans notre pays
la pénurie de masques et là la
communication malheureuse de trouve qui
a été fait
un certain moment par le gouvernement
j'ai vu que le 11 mars 2020 lors d'une
interview avec guillaume durand
donc on est le 11 mars
vous déclarez a pas à propos de la
fermeture des frontières
regardez l'italie ça a été le premier
pays pays a fermé ses frontières en
interdisant les vols en direction et en
provenance de la chine au moment de la
crise chinoise du climax de la crise
épidémique chinoise le résultat c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
l'épidémie est plus avancée en italie
qu'en france donc on voit bien qu un
virus un virus ça fait fi des frontières
est ce que vous êtes sûr que c'était
bien notre place que de commenter la
décision de l'italie qu'on ait vu des
communications malheureuse à l'intérieur
de notre pays
on en rediscutera
mais en l'occurrence critiqué la
position de l'italie
vu la situation dans laquelle elle était
déjà est-ce que vous pensez que c'était
opportun
et puis monsieur sciamma vous avez dit
dans votre présentation que les
autorités scientifiques était restée
silencieuse
j'ai bien écouté votre propos selon vous
qu'est ce qu'elle aurait pu faire
est-ce que vous pensez que si l'une ou
l'autre d'entre elles s'étaient exprimés
plus fermement
est ce que vous pensez qu effectivement
ça aurait pu j'exige et les positions de
certains scientifiques ou des médias
concernés merci merci madame la
sénatrice
vous m'interrogez au fond sur une
déclaration que j'ai eus dont je me
souviens très bien avec guillaume daret
je me permet de rendre son exact me
semble-t-il parce que je pense à devait
être sur france 2 alors sur la situation
et le commentaire que j'ai fait sur la
situation italienne
en vérité ça m'est arrivé je crois à
deux reprises publiquement dans des
interviews mais plus souvent dans des
conférences de presse à l'issue du
conseil des ministres d'avoir à répondre
à des questions comparant la situation
française à la situation un d'autres
pays en particulier en europe et
comparant les décisions qui étaient
prises en france et les décisions qui
étaient prises dans d'autres pays il y
avait deux sujets notamment dans au
moment que vous évoquez qui étaient des
sujets récurrents
il y avait un sujet qui était celui de
la fermeture des frontières y compris
parce qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
responsables politiques qui réclamaient
cette fermeture des frontières
considérant que c'était un bon moyen de
nous isoler de de nous permettre
d'empêcher l'introduction dû virus sur
le sol national
et de l'autre côté il y avait un débat
sur la question de la prise de
température dans les aéroports certains
considérant que
le fait de prendre la température à la
descente d avion était le moyen qui
permettrait d'empêcher l'introduction dû
virus sur notre territoire national ont
en tout cas un des moyens qui permettait
de le faire c'est parce que il y avait
un questionnement sur la comparaison
entre la stratégie française et la
stratégie d'autres pays que deux fait
j'étais amené à comparer ce que nous
faisions en france et 2 fait a commenté
ce qui se passait à l'étranger et pour
revenir précisément sur le cas des
frontières il y avait un débat à
l'époque rappelez vous on avait commencé
par on n'avait pas fermer les frontières
aux tout débuts pour les vols venant de
uralde et du hubei ni de la chine dans
son ensemble c'est quelque chose qui a
été fait plus tard mais je vous invite
et je crois que ça sera importante selon
notre audition à regarder où nous en
étions de la connaissance scientifique
à un moment tu es un moment tu es je
crois que c'est assez important
au tout début de la crise on ne savait
pas les premiers cas de mémoire sont
rapportés le dernier jour de l'année
2019 je pense qu'il faut attendre
quasiment la fin du mois de janvier ou
vers la troisième semaine de janvier
pour avoir l'assurance qu'on a une
transmission interhumaine de mémoire
de mémoire si j'ai bien noté c'est le 20
janvier que l' oms atteste exactement
troisième semaine de janvier que l' oms
atteste d'une j'avais dit un autre non
j'avais 10 janvier troisième semaine que
l'om est atteste d'une transmission
interhumaine
et quand on regarde ce que dit le cdc
qui est l'organisme européen d' alerte
sur les crises sanitaires
il ne pointe pas tout de suite le risque
d'une introduction sur le sol européen
et donc c'est compte tenu de cet
environnement là que la doctrine qui
était celle de nos autorités sanitaires
et dont du ministère de la santé n'a pas
été de fermer les frontières et donc le
sens de mon propos à ce moment là était
tout simplement de dire que en france
nous l'avions pas fait que dans d'autres
pays ça avait été le cas et que pour
autant cela n'avait pas empêché
l'introduction dû virus dans ces pays
d'ailleurs exactement au même titre que
dans notre pays notamment parce que un
des éléments qui étaient notre
difficulté c'est que compte tenu de
comment dire de la facilité à se
déplacer à travers le monde
vous auriez pu avoir des gens qui
étaient partis de lujan qui avait fait
escale à singapour qui s'était retrouvé
en angleterre et qui ensuite arrivés en
france
tout ça dans un espace de temps
relativement court et d'ailleurs on l'a
vu pour les contamines montjoie qui a
été le premier cluster qu'on a eu en
france ou en fait on avait des
britanniques dont une personne était
allé un congrès à singapour et qui était
arrivé 2 singapour en france voilà ce
que je voulais porter avocat votre
connaissance donc il ne s'agissait en
aucun cas de minorer ce qui est l action
et le combat difficile que mener nos
amis italiens mais tout simplement
d'établir le fait qu' il avait une
stratégie que nous en avions une autre
et que la stratégie italienne n'avait
pas permis d'empêcher l'introduction dû
virus sur son sol monsieur
merci pour votre question madame je ne
suis pas naïf je ne pense pas que on
peut arrêter la désinformation en
période épidémique simplement en tançant
les personnes qui la véhiculent mais je
pense néanmoins que si les autorités
médicales s'étaient exprimés et
peut-être pas tout au début parce qu'en
fait les les connaissances sont arrivés
peu à peu et je pense qu'elle aurait pu
avoir une expression de plus en plus
ferme à mesure que le temps avançait que
les choses étaient plus claires et j'ai
trouvé lesquels les quelques l autorité
aurait dû s'exprimer selon vous alors
j'ai cité donc la haine smg cité l'ordre
des médecins et la haute autorité de
santé de nul ne détient la vérité dans
ce domaine scientifique puisque c'est un
virus par définition qu'on ne connaît
pas alors je je pense que par exemple
sur les effets des traitements qui ont
été proposées peu à peu les choses se
sont éclaircies et et je je je pense que
les choses sont désormais claires et
qu'elles le sont depuis un moment c'est
en tout cas mon avis et je pense que je
le note en passant la quasi totalité des
journalistes scientifiques ont pris
cette position là sans se concerter
donc je pense que les autorités
médicales sur la base des études
existantes aurait dû prendre des
positions plus fermes je pense qu'ils
auraient dû se concerter entre elles
probablement pour parler d'une seule
voix et que ceux ci auraient permis au
moins au public d'avoir un point de vue
de la science qui s'expriment et qui
soit visible et identifiable ensuite le
public choisit qui il écoute et qu'il
n'écoute pas mais l'atmosphère là était
que tout
valais et que tous les points de vue
étaient également recevable ce qui n'est
pas le cas à mes yeux très bien bernard
jomier merci monsieur le président je
peux je partage je voudrais dire en
introduction ce que le président a dit
sur le fait que l'intérêt pour moi de
cette audition n'est pas de revenir sur
les déclarations qui ont pu être un peu
erratique sont révélées fausses et c'est
assez c'est pas tellement là dessus
qu'on va enfin à mon sens qu'on va tirer
des leçons qui sont très instructives il
ya eu un ldd des bêtises qui ont été
dites qui était liée à l'état de la
connaissance au temps t et il y en a
d'autres qui ont été dites et là qui
révèle d'une logique de de communication
politique et c'est celle là qui sont
plus qui pose plus de questions moi
j'étais très intéressé par ce que vous
avez dit l'un à l'autre vous monsieur
sciamma vous avez beaucoup parlé du
fonds en fait
et à mon avis vous avez dit des choses
essentielles parce qu'évidemment la
communication elle n'est que le reflet
de ce que de la pensée ou du non dit
dans l'action que l'on mène
vous avez dit quelque chose qui à mon
sens est essentiel qui est que le virus
aurait dû nous permettent de faire bloc
et celle inverse qui s'est produit
et ça ça me paraît fondamental parce
qu'une épidémie c'est effectivement une
interaction entre un microbe et une
société et ce qui va se passer est
essentielle en la matière la façon dont
la société va se regrouper et va se
protège et collectivement
quel mécanisme elle va mettre en oeuvre
va être une grande partie du succès ou
de l'échec de la lutte contre l'épidémie
et à cet égard
moi je suis très interrogatif de
l'entrée dans la communication des
autorités gouvernementales de l'entrée
dans l'épidémie
j'ai été très marqué par la journée du
29 février
ce jour là le conseil des ministres est
convoqué pour parler de la lutte contre
l'épidémie et mobiliser notre pays faire
ce bloc et faire cette société et à la
surprise générale le gouvernement le
premier ministre décide ce même jour qui
va engager la responsabilité des
gouvernements sur le sujet le plus
clivants du moment la réforme des
retraites
et je trouve que cette conjonction est
extrêmement malheureuse parce que elle
fait du gouvernement qui doit se mettre
en marche et qui doit nous rassembler
pour lutter contre le virus
un gouvernement qui dans le même temps
on voit un message de fracture politique
et je me demande comment quand on fonde
aussi mal qu'on creuse aussi mal les
fondations de la maison on peut
construire après un défi difficile tient
debout et je pense que cette ya eu là et
j'aimerais entendre évidemment madame la
ministre sur ce sujet il me semble qu'il
ya eu il ya un peu une peut-être une
erreur en tout cas quelque chose qui
était incompréhensible pour notre
opinion publique et qui fait qu est ce
que vous avez dit l'un et l'autre à la
difficulté dans notre période actuelle
je reviendrai pas sur les causes mais de
créer un lien de confiance entre des
autorités quelles qu'elles soient et
notre peuple et les gens madame la
ministre avait dit iain demande de
transparence et d'horizontalité mais
quand c'est la guerre il ya ni
transparence neorizons horizontalité on
ne gère pas une guerre par la
transparence ni on ne la mène pas dans
l'horizontalité ou alors c'est que ce
n'était pas la guerre à ce moment là il
faut avoir pareil une cohérence donc
comment comment notre pays est entré
dans cette épidémie comment nos
principaux responsables sont entrés dans
cette épidémie avec des messages aussi
discordants
soit c'était délibéré soit il y avait un
défaut de préparation un défaut de
culture de santé publique vous dites un
défaut de culture scientifique dans nos
pays mais j'aimerais aussi vous entendre
là dessus comment comment avez vous
perçu comment avez vous vu
q l'entrée du pays dans l'épidémie en
fonction de ce qu'il était et de ce que
de ce qu'étaient ces ressorts
voilà je m'en tiendrai là monsieur le
président merci monsieur le sénateur
vous évoquez à travers votre question
comme on dit des éléments qui moi même
mon beaucoup interrogé je m'explique le
début de l'épidémie qu'on n'appelait pas
une épidémie à l'époque commence par le
signalement par la chine de cadres de
pneumopathie atypique on est le 31
décembre 2019 à partir de là assez
classiquement les uns et les autres
s'interrogent que se passe-t-il de quoi
il s'agit exactement dès le 10 janvier
le ministère de la santé
envoie des messages d'alerté aux ars on
en attendait il ya il se passe un truc
on nous en a parlé il ya une quinzaine
de jours on vous met un message d'
alerte sur l'existence de cette ne m'ont
pas tissé un message alerte qui part aux
ars
on sait pas l'époque à la transmission
interhumaine ça arrive dix jours plus
tard le lendemain du moment où on a une
transmission interhumaine qui est avérée
la ministre de la santé
donc on peut dire c'est pas le premier
ministre par le président de la
république mais la ministre de la santé
fait une première conférence de presse
pour évoquer ce nouveau virus qui vient
de rompre and en tant que nous dise
quand vous faites une conférence de
presse sur un sujet c'est que vous
considérez que il est important que y
ait une discussion politique en tout cas
qui s'entame sur un sujet moi je fais
pas d jamais fait des conférences de
presse parce que ça me plaisait
particulièrement mais c'est parce que
j'avais quelque chose à dire et donc
pour moi c'est la preuve que d'abord il
n'y avait pas de notre côté du côté de
l'exécutif
quelque part une légèreté consistant à
considérer qu' il n'y avait rien qui se
passait et de manière très précoce avant
même que l' oms ne parle d' urgence de
santé publique internationale ou même de
pandémie ce qui est arrivé beaucoup plus
tard on a eu quelques jours après cette
conférence le premier quart en france
qui était un cas importé et le 26
janvier ont fait une réunion
interministérielle autour du premier
ministre et un dimanche cette réunion
interministérielle elle se fait à
l'initiative donc du premier ministre
avec autour de lui
de mémoire le la ministre des armées le
ministre de l'intérieur nice de la santé
pour parole du gouvernement
et je ne suis pas sûr que le ministre
des affaires étrangères et était là mais
en tout cas c'est sûr qu'il était
représenté par son directeur de cabinet
puisque le sujet qui nous préoccupe
à ce moment là comme lorsqu'on a une
situation complexe à l'étranger c'est la
question du rapatriement éventuel de nos
compatriotes
ce rapatriement rappelez vous il se fait
sur la base du volontariat
parce que à ce moment là nous n'avons
pas de données qui nous permettent de
nous dire dans quelle phase accroît ce à
quoi exactement nous faisons face si je
vous donne cette petite chronologie
c'est pour vous dire que le 29 février
donc on est déjà là un mois plus tard je
sais plus combien de cas on a en france
à cette date là mais je me souviens en
revanche très bien que les interviews
que je donnais en janvier en février
était majoritairement consacré encore
majoritairement consacrés au sujet de la
réforme des retraites et qu'on avait
progressivement de mémoire ça doit être
le 28 janvier que je fais une première
interview on me pose la question mais
sous l'angle rapatriement puis
progressivement au cours du mois de
janvier le sujet monte en puissance
médiatiquement et donc il faut bien voir
qu'à cette époque là dans le pays le
questionnement d'actualité d'actualité
pardon était pas forcément était encore
la réforme des retraites avec moi par
revenir sur le contexte les raisons qui
nous ont conduits à vouloir mener cette
réforme est donc le conseil des
ministres dont vous parlez auquel j'ai
assisté est un conseil des ministres
dans le dans lequel on passe la majorité
du temps à informer l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement sur la situation
de ce début d'épidémie sur les
dispositions qui doivent être prises et
du temps effectivement mais moins
important consacré aux 49 3 vous parlez
de fracture politique au lieu de
rassemblement c'est pour ça que je vous
fais au fond cette espèce de film sur là
où on en était de la perception de la
situation
vous évoquez le fait que en temps de
guerre on peut avoir ni transparence ni
horizontalité moi je crois pas du tout
ça je crois que la maturation de nos
démocraties
elle conduit aujourd'hui à ce que les
citoyens soient pas le doigt sur la
couture du pantalon pour obéir à des
injonctions politiques
il ya besoin de pédagogie de
compréhension et c'est à travers la
transparence concret de l'adhésion et
c'est ce à quoi j'ai essayé dans la
mesure de mes moyens de répondre et
cette transparence
quand bien même vous ne voudriez pas la
voir elle vous est imposé elle vous est
imposée parce que vous avez des experts
médicaux qui sont sur les plateaux de
télévision
parce que vous avez énormément de gens
qui prennent la parole sur les réseaux
sociaux chacun chacun étant au fond son
propre média
donc vous pouvez faire comme si ça
n'existait pas mais il se trouve que
cette transparence à elle existe est de
mon point de vue le devoir dans notre
démocratie avec son degré de maturité de
l'exécutif et de répondre à cette
exigence de transparence pour autant le
conseil de défense sanitaire est couvert
par le secret défense
mais tout n'est pas rendue publique dans
les décisions
mais le maximum doit être rendu public
de mon point de vue vous m'avez posé la
question de comment on est rentré dans
l'épidémie on y rentrer de manière
concentrée en sachant qu'on marchait
dans des sables mouvants
parce qu'en fait quand nous interrogions
les sachants il visitait il savait pas
complètement mais c'est complètement
normal parce que c'était un virus auquel
nous
on jamais été confronté je rajouterais
deux éléments pour conclure ce propos je
crois qu'on a souffert au cours de cette
crise d'un défaut d'acculturation
scientifique de la population française
autrement dit quand on devait expliquer
que pour pouvoir tester un traitement
il fallait faire ce qu'on appelle les
bras qui permettent d'expérimenter la
validité d'un traitement que ça prenait
des semaines et des semaines on était
confronté à des gens sur des plateaux de
télévision ou même à des citoyens qui
vous interroger dans vos déplacements
quand on pouvait encore se déplacer qui
vous disais mais pourquoi c'est pas oui
ou non
3 c'est pas blanc ou noir et pourquoi ce
n'est pas tout de suite comment vous
vous qui êtes recensé être l'élite
politique médicale le décideur vous êtes
incapable de nous dire si c'est
maintenant tout de suite et expliqué
comparé d'hypothèses que ces hypothèses
doivent être soumises doivent être
testés qu'ensuite il faut qu'ils aient
de la convergence pour que plusieurs
bras expérimentaux sur les médicaments
convergent pour donner la même réponse
et que c'est à partir de là qu'on
donnera une réponse définitive
ça a été très difficile et ça marque
aussi le rapport au temps de notre
société
aujourd'hui on veut que d'un claquement
de doigts toutes les réponses à toutes
les questions qu'on se pose soit
apporter immédiatement et dès que vous
aller sur un plateau de télévision quand
vous êtes un rap à un décideur politique
pour dire c'est plus compliqué que ça
réfléchissons prenons le temps on vous
accuse d'atermoyer on vous dit que vous
n'allez pas assez vite et si on va en
suivant le fil de cette crise plus loin
notamment au moment du décompte final
rappelons-nous chacun les interventions
qui voulait ouvrir les parcs et jardins
tout de suite alors qu' il y avait des
doutes des incertitudes sur le fait que
ça pouvait être bénéfique dans un moment
de déconfinement voilà je voulais
terminer en disant qu'il y avait sans
doute aussi ces deux sujets là qu'il
fallait prendre en compte mais qu'en
aucun cas le gouvernement
je crois n'avait manqué ni de serrer ni
de célérité ni de concentration ni
d'attention au moment de rentrer dans
cette pandémie je vous remercie
d'ailleurs je m'amuse mais juste un
point le meilleur comme
ni quand je ne sais pas comment il peut
résoudre cette équation de dire on est
en guerre
il faut de la transparence et
l'horizontalité déjà c'est pardon mais
ces deux notions sont quand même je le
maintiens difficilement compatibles et
tout ça est dirigée par un conseil de
défense qui siège en secret alors
l'opinion publique moi je comprends que
elle ne comprend plus rien je veux dire
ce sont des de tels messages
contradictoires
et comme on en a vécu beaucoup je ne dis
pas que la résolution est simple jeu
je suis juste en train de dire que
politiquement ces choix là peut-être où
cette oscillation de choix et de valeurs
est le témoin d'une impréparation
collective qui est qui laquelle on peut
remonter en amont autant qu'on veut mais
en tout cas il me semble que ça explique
une difficulté bien légitime de
l'opinion publique à comprendre ces
messages contradictoires et dernier
point rapide mais comme vous l'avez
abordé l'ouverture ou la fermeture des
parcs et jardins publics
est ce que c'est bien du ressort du chef
de l'état d'aller prendre ce décision de
savoir si non quelle ville on doit
maintenir les parcs et jardins publics
fermés alors que tout le travail qu'on a
fait depuis des mois démontrent que la
stratégie nationale est fondamentale
mais c'est au niveau des territoires
qu'elle s'applique
intelligemment et avec l'implication des
différents des différents acteurs là
encore il ya une contradiction qui est
tout de même difficile à comprendre à
appréhender
monsieur permettez monsieur ciapa et je
vous redonne la parole
sciama pardon je vous redonne la parole
après je remercie je voudrais juste
faire un commentaire sur la difficulté
d'agir et de s'exprimer en contexte
d'incertitude nous nous avons tous
ressenti cela est
nos journalistes un degré bien moindre
par rapport à vous politique mais il
fallait quand même écrire des choses et
savoir qu'on pouvait nous les reprocher
s'il était démentie je ne pense pas que
ce soit un exercice impossible
je pense que peut-être que nous avons
une culture en particulier du côté des
autorités et des sachant qu' une culture
de la communication un peu autoritaire
et qui ne laisse pas la place à
l'incertitude et qui ne laisse pas je
pense que les gens peuvent comprendre
l'incertitude les gens peuvent
comprendre que pour l'instant on ne sait
pas cela on attend les résultats de
telles études de tels inquiet de telles
enquêtes de telles expériences et
qu'ensuite on pourra trancher et que
néanmoins en attendant on est obligé de
prendre des décisions qui seront peut
être réévalués je ne pense pas que la
communication gouvernementale est
toujours eu ce ton souple je les
trouvais parfois verticale et on voir
punitive
alors que il me semble que le public
aurait mieux compris un ton de ce type
voilà je pense que notre institution
médicale a également une tendance à
s'exprimer comme ça en dix ans la
science et en avec un ton plus
autoritaire encore plus quand on ne sait
pas vraiment et que ça donne un résultat
regrettable merci vous souhaitiez
rajouter mal souhaité merci beaucoup
monsieur le président dire deux choses
sur la communication qui a que vous
qualifié d'autoritaire ça devenait
quasiment une blague
à chacune de mes interventions que les
journalistes me faisais et c'était assez
désagréable s'était alors si tu nous dis
encore à ce stade ça va pas aller et au
tout au long de ma communication le à ce
stade compte tenu de nos informations et
jusqu'à nouvel ordre était quasiment des
ponctuations de mes phrases
malheureusement force est de constater
que ça n'a jamais été entendu et que
quand j'ai eu des assertions qui était à
un instant t
valable qui se sont révélés plus valable
quelques jours quelques semaines plus
tard on ne sait jamais souvenu de à ce
stade on s'est toujours souvenu de ce
qui précédait donc c'est une vraie
difficulté
j'allais dire presque cognitives ou en
fait on est on est dans un moment où
tout le monde a peur dans un moment où
on a besoin d'assurances et chacun
s'accroche aux moindres au bout de
phrase qui permet d'avoir cette
assurance est malheureusement bien
la communication quand vous devez l
affaire sur twitter ce qui est retenu
dans un tweet c'est pas exactement la
complexité de ce que vous avez voulu
dire et quand il a été twitter mes
propos c'était rarement avec le à ce
stade où le jusqu'à nouvel ordre
deuxièmement sur le sujet du niveau
local et du niveau national
c'est un sujet qui est complexe parce
que vous devez élaborer une stratégie
qui est national dans cette stratégique
et national les préconisations que vous
fonder sa chance et il faut éviter que
les gens se rassemblent dans un endroit
d'abord en priorité il faut pas qu'ils
se rassemblent dans des endroits qui
sont clos et puis par ailleurs il faut
pas qu'il sera sans non plus dans des
endroits quand ils se rassemblent à
nombreux même quand ils sont à
l'extérieur c'était en tout cas un
moment donné la préconisation qu'on
avait donc dans ce contexte là vous
intégrer dans votre stratégie nationale
que les gens ne se rassemblent pas dans
les parcs et jardins c'est pour vous
faire le répondre à la question sur
qu'est ce qui se décide au niveau
national et qu'est ce qui se décide au
niveau local ça n'empêche pas ensuite
qu'en fonction des territoires
quand vous êtes sur les grandes plages
de bretagne effectivement le local vous
fait remonter que c'est pourtant
compatibles et que l'utilisation locale
qui est faite de cet espace-là permet
d'autoriser l'ouverture
quand vous êtes dans le square montholon
que je connais bien
vous êtes en plein air mais bien bien
passer les uns sur les autres
voilà les petites précisions monsieur le
sénateur je me dis que je souhaitais
apporter à mon propos je vous remercie
si catherine des roches me le permet
bien merci
j'ai été surpris par vos propos m
vous dites qu'en temps de crise
transparence dans la communication
pédagogie compréhension et vous n'avez
pas employer un mot qui serait simple et
compris par tout le monde dira la vérité
et vous parler de défaut d'acculturation
scientifique de la population
je sais ce que c'est pas la marque quand
on dit que effectivement la population
n'a plus confiance est là une défiance
par rapport aux autorités est-ce que
c'est pas la marque de la défiance des
autorités par rapport à la population
parce que c'est interactif cette
affaire-là
donnez nous des précisions dans le
sentiment là le mot vérité doit
ressortir de notre commission denquête
monsieur sciamma vous avez parlé de
verticalité et de communication voire
punitive
merci de nous donner juste quelques
exemples précis madame merci monsieur le
président vous avez évidemment raison
dire la vérité sur ce qu'on sait et sur
ce qu'on ne sait pas en temps de crise
est primordiale et je crois que c'est ce
à quoi nous nous sommes collectivement
attaché dans l'exécuter de vous sur à
oui j'en suis certaine par rapport aux
masques par rapport au masque bien sûr
par rapport au masque bien sûr nous
avons dit ce que nous savions nous avons
établi une doctrine d'emploi
nous avons rendu cette doctrine d'emploi
transparente dans la doctrine d'emploi
il y avait une priorité qui était donnée
au personnel soignant dans les hôpitaux
je pense que le ministère le ministre de
la santé qui sera auditionné je crois
demain
pardon c'est demain par votre commission
aura l'occasion d'y revenir
mais moi à aucun moment on ne m'a
demandé de mentir sur ce qui était la
situation des masques et à aucun moment
donné je les fais et sur la question de
l'utilisation des masques
je vous rappelle je me permets de me
pencher dessus
le 30 mars le 30 mars l'om s estime
qu'il n'y a pas de preuve de l'utilité
en population générale sur le masque le
30 mars
je peux pas vous dire autre chose que
nous sommes basés sur ce qu'ils étaient
et et je reviens d'ailleurs sur sur le
l'académie de médecine ne préconise le
masque en population générale qu'à
compter du 3 avril
mes conseils l'académie de médecine je
peux vous assurer qu'il ne communiquait
pas en fonction des desiderata du
gouvernement
très loin de là donc je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse les accusés d'avoir fait ou
dit ça à partir du moment où ça aurait
été au portant pour le gouvernement
ensuite mais je crois que le sujet de la
défiance envers le politique avec un
grand p
c'est pas un sujet qui date
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas un sujet qui
datent de cette crise c'est
malheureusement quelque chose qui minent
la des mines aux démocraties
occidentales mais c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que à travers le monde vous pouvez
avoir l'émergence de mouvements
populistes qui conduisent à avoir des
autorités très autoritaire d'ailleurs et
donc nous avons pâti pendant cette crise
de 7,2 ce manque de confiance envers les
autorités au sens large
qu'elles soient politiques médicales
voire même dans le pouvoir qu incarne
les médias pour revenir sur le thème
d'acculturation il s'agissait pas pour
moi d'être du tout méprisante à l'égard
de nos concitoyens mais simplement de
refléter ce que j'avais vécu en étant au
contact de gens parfois sur les plateaux
de télévision
parfois au cours des déplacements
lorsqu'il était encore possible
où on nous disait et moi je les prie
j'allais dire en pleine face si j'ose
dire pourquoi vous savez pas tout de
suite à quoi vous servez si vous savez
pas tout de suite et expliqué que en
fait le professeur raoul peut-être qu'il
avait un bras d'expérimentation qui
était en cours mais qu'il y en avait
d'autres qui ont testé des choses
différentes à des stades précoces de la
maladie à des stades avancés de la
maladie à des stades pré en de manière
préventive et que nous n'avions pas
encore les résultats je ne pourrais pas
dire quelque chose que je ne savais pas
et on me disait oui mais en fait est là
on avait quelque chose qui se
télescopaient qui était vous ne voulez
pas de raul tu parce que en fait c'est
un médecin marseillais et c'est le
peuple contre les élites et donc on
avait un maelström de choses très
différentes qui était à la fois qu'elle
était là le cheminement scientifiques
qu'on pouvait avoir pour pouvoir dire
oui ou non ça marche ou ça marche pas et
en même temps vous aviez des
considérations politiques qui rentrait
en ligne de compte et les deux mêlées
effectivement produit d'une situation
qui est assez inextricables et dans
lequel être audible il n'est pas
forcément évident je le reconnais bien
volontiers
je suis le seul à ma jeu je reconnais
que le terme punitif peut paraître
excessif je faisais référence aux
interventions qu'on a par exemple eu du
ministre de l'intérieur qui rappelait
les sanctions en cas de non obéissance
aux règles sanitaires et je je je ne me
pose pas ce qui est des sanctions c'est
normal mais il ya quand même une
question de tonj je sais pas si vous
êtes familier de l'exemple allemand mais
en allemagne le professeur draw steyn
qui est un virologue éminent s'adressait
très souvent au public y compris assez
longuement en faisant beaucoup de
pédagogie et j'ai dit j'ai quand même
trouvé que la pédagogie avait manqué à
travers cet épisode qu'il aurait fallu
trouver du temps et des espaces pour
simplement expliqué répondre aux
questions grands détaillants ne cachant
rien des incertitudes
nous avons essayé de le faire dans les
médias avec les moyens qu'on avait mais
je pense que ça aurait été bien vu de la
part de l'autorité sous des formes que
qu'il faut qu'il faudra avoir imaginé
voilà merci quelques mots justes de
réagir sur le sujet d'abord de d'un
caractère punitif et plantu de la
pédagogie sur le sujet la pédagogie le
directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon a fait des conférences de presse
quotidiennes quasiment sans limitation
du nombre de questions qui pouvaient lui
être posée alors dans les circonstances
qu'on connaît avec un journaliste qui
est médiateur et c'est le premier
ministre comme le ministre de la santé
ont eux mêmes fait des conférences de
presse dont d'ailleurs les niveaux
d'audience reflète ce que vous dites
c'est à dire le fait qu'il y avait un
appétit pour delà de la pédagogie
mais je crois honnêtement je j'ai le
sentiment que on a en tout cas donner
les outils pour que cette pédagogie soit
possible et on y reviendra peut-être
mais le s iger a constitué un hub avec
des centaines de questions up pardon sur
internet à partir de la page
gouvernement.fr avec des centaines de
questions réponses sur ce qu'il faut
connaître du coronavirus et les
questions que vous vous posez
deuxième chose sur le sainte sur le sur
la question punitive
une communication qui pourrait
apparaître comme verticale et punitive
la nouveau je vous remet dans le
contexte dans lequel on était au tout
début de la crise incertitude sur la
gravité de la maladie
incertitude sur ses modalités de
propagation etc et on avait une
difficulté d'ailleurs qu'on a vu jusqu'à
la veille des élections municipales qui
était qu' il n'y avait pas forcément de
prise de conscience collective de la
gravité de la situation et on avait du
mal à faire passer les sujets de base de
gestes barrières de distance physique et
c est donc au fond en communication vous
vous posez la question est ce que vous
faites comme de la sécurité routière ou
pas à un moment donné pour saisir
j'allais dire intellectuellement
la population ce qui permet à près de
dérouler une communication qui va plus
dans la pédagogie vous avez vu les clips
divers et variés du scg qui expliquait
comment cela vraiment comme on se tient
à distance etc etc et donc il ya eu un
moment donné on a eu besoin de saisir
j'allais dire intellectuellement les
individus pour faire prendre conscience
d'eux et après on a eu une communication
et vous le retrouverez dans mes
interventions qui disait beaucoup on a
une responsabilité collective mais une
responsabilité individuelle chacun à
notre place on peut faire quelque chose
pour aider à la freiner la propagation
du virus donc on a en permanence jouer
en quelque sorte sur ces deux ressorts
là à la fois une interpellation
collective et en même temps une mise en
responsabilité individuelle je vous
remercie et bien fait madame évidemment
que tout n'a pas été bien fait parce que
dans une entreprise humaine
à aucun moment vous ne pouvez avoir un
20 sur 20 c'est pas l'école donc si
vital pour moi évidemment il ya des
choses qui ont été moins bien réussi et
je les ai d'ailleurs moi même reconnaît
déjà si katherine merci monsieur le
président avec vous avez parlé défiance
mais au fil de ses auditions
comment voulez vous qu'il n'y ait pas
une forme de défiance de la population
dans la mesure où deux
de l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement on nous n'avons eu aucune
autocritique aucune autocritique et vous
mais madame la ministre vous nous
expliquer alors j'entends le fait que
les connaissances ont évolué que la
situation évoluer sur un virus que l'on
ne connaissait pas mais à aucun moment
on entend une autocritique en disant à
tel moment en effet la communication
nous avons fait n'était pas correct
quand vous dites les autorités genre
haut conseil de santé publique academy
médecine nous avons auditionné la
semaine dernière le professeur
delfraissy
alors il ne l'a pas dit de la façon
peut-être aussi clair que je vais le
dire mais moi j'ai ressenti dans ce
qu'ils nous disaient sur la
communication et des avis du conseil
scientifique que il les avait il avait
donné des avis compatible avec ce qui
existait c'est à dire que leur avis et
est compatible sur les tests ou sur les
masses avec la situation qui existait un
moment je me suis dit c'est peut-être la
seule à avoir compris cela mais en fait
en interrogeant l'ensemble des collègues
c'est quand même ce qu'il a dit de façon
implicite
donc moi je veux bien tout entendre mais
quand on compare la situation et vous
avez fait référence monsieur la
situation entre entre la france et
l'allemagne a quand même des différences
de résultats qui sont traînés et sûre
sur les tests notamment le professeur
flahault la semaine dernière nous a dit
clairement il y avait des dès janvier
des théories bon celle du professeur
raoul qui disait il faut tester tester
pour pouvoir isoler professeur flahault
nous a dit bolt est clivant donc en fait
tout le monde a mis un peu de côté ce
qu'il disait mais le professeur leur
stand disait exactement la même chose en
allemagne mais de façon peut-être en
effet consensuel comme vous l'avez
évoqué mais lui nous a dit nous comme
épidémiologistes on n'était pas sur
l'idée de tester en disant n'y a pas de
traitement ça ne sert à rien de tester
mes dix en fait ceux qui disaient qu'il
fallait tester dès le départ avait
raison donc quand vous nous dites nous
les journalistes scientifiques on a été
unanime sur ce que vous a été unanime
pratiquement sur notre vision des
traitements des résultats les autres
comment voulez vous que l'on puisse
croire que tous les journalistes qui ont
des formations scientifiques différentes
et je respecte tout à fait votre
profession bien évidemment et votre
formation
comment peut-on croire que vous étiez
unanime alors que des des gens comme le
professeur flahault ou d'autres nous
disent on on s'est plantés à un moment
entre guillemets par rapport à la
connaissance et on aurait dû plus
écouter les virologues que les
épidémiologistes nous voyez c'est très
compliqué et et moi ce que je voudrais
savoir c'est comment vous vous êtes vous
vous informer sur la communication que
vous faites dans vos revues quelles sont
vos sources
puisqu'on a vu quand même un journal
comme le lance est sorti une étude bidon
nitoo bidon suivie immédiatement par la
réaction du ministre de la santé
d'interdire un traitement donc comment
vous vous travaillez vos journalistes
scientifiques durant cette épidémie
comment vous avez travaillez vous nous
avez dit on sait très bien que les
proxys chloroquine ne marche pas mon
avis aussi ce qui s'était passé pour
leur md et vire qui a obtenu une
autorisation de mise sur le marché par
l' agence européenne et dont on nous dit
qu'il est en cours encore décès dans
certains bras d'essai clinique qu'il est
encore en autorisations temporaires
d'utilisation de kort et dont le
professeur les scientifiques on a
entendu la semaine dernière nous ont dit
qu'en fait il avait très peu de de
preuves par quoi cela marche donc voyez
c'est plus compliqué que je trouve ccc
verdict très clair en disant celui ci
marche pas mais celui ci pourrait
marcher
je pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur le traitement pour
l'instant on n'a pas de traitement comme
on a pas de vaccin d'ailleurs mais moi
je voudrais vraiment savoir comment vous
vous raisonnez pour nous affirmer que
vous les journalistes scientifiques vous
avez pratiquement tout bien fait durant
cette crise et que ce sont les autres
qui ont eu tort quant à vous madame la
ministre je ne sais pas quoi vous vous
poser comme question puisque c'est
compliqué il vous remettez en cause qui
a été fait moi j'aimerais quand même
vous poser une question
c'est sur la place de la communication
du conseil scientifique
alors certains nous ont dit dans
certains pays c'est plus le
le comment dire celui qui sait sur le
plan sanitaire qui communiquent plus que
le gouvernement mais nous on a eu à la
fois une communication du gouvernement
parfois en effet chaotique mais bon en
période de crise on peut expliquer
parfois un certain chaos dans la
communication et en même temps
conseiller scientifique qui donnait des
avis qui communiqué que l'on mettait en
avant qui était sensé pour éclairer la
décision politique est parfois on
suivait ses avis parfois on ne suivait
pas ses avis tout ça à participer à une
confusion totale à mon sens est ce que
là ya pas eu une erreur dans la façon
dont on en a on a donné une place
publique et et et extérieurs au conseil
scientifique
merci monsieur sciamma je regrette de
vous avoir donné l'impression que je
prétendais à l'infaillibilité c'est pas
du tout le cas ni ni ni moi ni ma
profession je peux vous donner un
exemple sur l'idh roxy chloroquine sur
laquelle j'ai écrit un article dans le
courant du mois d'avril dans cet article
j'ai écrit que à ce moment là on ne
pouvait pas être sûr que ça ne marchait
pas mais on pouvait être sûr que c'était
au mieux un petit médicaments c'est à
dire qu' il soit il n'avait pas d'effet
soit il avait un effet modeste et je
pense que depuis il s'avérait qu'en fait
il y avait pas d'effet du tout mais
quand on compte quand nous écrivons en
fait nous nous interviewons les
spécialistes le plus grand nombre de
spécialistes possible la règle c'est ou
1,3 pour faire un papier
enfin à l'écrit en télé des fois ça va
beaucoup plus vite que ça et nous
essayons de prendre le pouls et ensuite
d'écrire des choses un peu nuancé qui
laisse ouvertes les portes je voulais
dire simplement que nous n'avons pas
enfin dans l'ensemble écrits de choses
scandaleuses de choses qui ont été
complètement démentie par la suite
d'affirmations outrageante comme on en a
eu plein sur les télés d'information
continue en particulier donc sur les
masques sur l'idh roxy chloroquine sur
voilà des sujets comme ça je pense que
globalement ce que nous avons écrit
reflète-t-elle savoir au moment où nous
l'avons écrit c'est pas plus prétentieux
que ça ce que ce que j'avance voilà
merci sur les tests la plupart d'entre
nous avons dès le début repris la
formule de l'om est-ce du président de
l'om est ce qu'ils disaient il faut
tester tester tester et je crois que la
plupart d'entre nous on s'est alignée
derrière ça on se rend compte
aujourd'hui que c'est un peu plus
compliqué et que peut-être qu'il faut
prioriser etc mais sur le fond c'est
quand même mieux de tester que d'aller
dans le brouillard une remarque
permettez-moi de médecins généralistes
pendant trente ans il n'y a pas de
petits médicaments monsieur parce qu'un
médicament qui redonne confiance est un
grand médicament pour certains madame
dionne plusieurs éléments pour vous
répondre madame la sénatrice de roche
d'abord sur la question de
l'autocritique
vous savez pendant la crise du gros
navires us en tout cas le temps que moi
j'ai été en fonction j'ai compté j'ai
fait 80 10 apparitions médiatiques en
six mois je n'aurais jamais la
prétention de dire que sur 90
apparitions médiatiques en comptant les
interviews les matinales et conférence
de presse que je n'ai jamais fait
d'erreur et donc à titre personnel oui
j'ai eu des phrases qui était maladroite
qui parce qu'elle est est alambiquée
parce que les exemples était mal choisi
françon particulier une polémique sur
les enseignants à un moment donné était
inadéquate gelé d'ailleurs reconnu
immédiatement parce que j'estime que
quand on est responsable politique il
faut toujours reconnaître ses erreurs et
donc en l'occurrence quand j'ai eu des
phrases qui étaient des phrases
inadéquate malheureuse maladroite je
crois que j'ai en tout cas essayer de
systématiquement le dire après dans ma
position de porte parole du gouvernement
ce que je vous ai expliqué c'est que
j'avais à rendre publics et à diffuser
les décisions qui était prise par mes
collègues ministres dont je suis
évidemment parfaitement solidaire mais
je n'ai pas la prétention non plus
d'avoir la science total et sur les
stratégies qui ont été mises en oeuvre
elles m'ont été expliqué
ça me paraissait d'un point de vue
intellectuel tout à fait valable et donc
je les aient relayé ce qui ne m'empêche
pas évidemment d'en être parfaitement
solidaire politiquement sur la question
de des avis du conseil scientifique de
ce que vous avez paru ressentir peux
malheureusement pas vous répondre parce
que dans pas moi-même conseil
scientifique
j'aurais bien du mal à dire comment est
ce que dans le sein de leurs instances
ils ont construit cette décision ce qui
est certain c'est que pour conjurer leur
décision il disposait des outils
d'information sur la situation sanitaire
du pays qui leur permettait de forger
une opinion donc après comment est-ce
que cette opinion s'est forgé sa
évidemment je ne me permettrais en aucun
cas de le dire à la place du conseil
scientifique vous posez la question de
l'équilibré entre eux la parole
scientifique celle qui émane du conseil
scientifique mais aussi du haut conseil
pour la santé publique d'autres
instances et celle du politique
je voudrais vous rappeler qu'au tout
début lorsque les avis du conseil
scientifique était pas rendu public on a
eu une très forte pression qui par
ailleurs pour moi me paraît légitime
pour qu'ils soient rendues publiques
parce qu'on nous accusait au fond d'être
dans une situation où on avait des
décisions ou des recommandations qui
était prise dans une instance secrète
don en fait sur laquelle nous nous
appuyons pour nous donner nos propres
décisions politiques sans qu'on sache
bien au fond ce qui était dit et je me
rappelle de nombreux responsables
politiques qui ont réclamé à ce que les
avis du conseil scientifique soit rendue
publique
ça me paraissait légitime que
ces avis soit rendue publique y compris
parce que nous avons toujours assumé que
nous avons que nous appuyons nos
décisions sur un rationnel scientifique
et sanitaires mais que la décision in
fine et revenez aux politiques parce que
à la fin des fins c'est nous qui sommes
responsables y compris devant la
représentation nationale et nous avons
toujours assumé les décisions
scientifiques et les décisions pardon
politiques y compris dans un moment je
pense notamment au moment du des
confirmands où nous avons pris en compte
un avis sanitaires mais aussi une
situation éducative une situation
économique et une situation sociale et
c'est la conjonction au fond de ces
différentes disciplines si j'ose dire
qui a conduit à la décision qui a été
prise sur la date du déconfinement avec
évidemment un questionnement
démocratiques légitimes questionnement
politique légitime qui était est ce que
c'est une bonne décision ou pas mais
faire de la politique et gouverner c'est
choisir et c'est parfois choisir la
moins mauvaise des mauvaises solutions
merci catherine des roches oui votre
avis à vous journalistes scientifiques
sur justement cette parole du conseil
scientifique qui intervenait au moment
du juste avant que le politique
intervienne qu'elle vous êtes d'accord
vos accès des notions de de transparence
voulue vous nous détendre des pressions
des pressions de qui l'opinion publique
responsables politiques ont réclamé ça
mais j'ai le souvenir à l'époque que des
responsables politiques en particulier
dans l'opposition ont demandé à ce que
ces avis soient rendus publics
et je vous dit à titre personnel j'ai
adhère complètement parce que dès lors
que vous avez une instance dont les
membres sont connus ya pas de raison qu
elle puisse pas rentrer à vie publique
effectivement devant le micro madame
qu'on puisse bien entendre donc vous
n'avez pas le nom des responsables
politiques à venir souhaiter que c'est
sa visite ici mais dans mon souvenir sur
le conseil sur mais alors c'est ça
devait être avant j'ai pu le soutenir
mais en tout cas j'ai le sou j'ai le
souvenir m'est donc c'était avant j'ai
le souvenir d'avoir peut-être que c'est
un souvenir qui est erronée que c'est ma
mémoire king trahi parce que vous nous
fait douter du coup mais je le souvenir
d'avoir eu à répondre sur des plateaux à
des interpellations dix ans dans
l'opposition réclame que et donc
qu'est-ce que vous répondez
merci monsieur sont là je voulais juste
dire que pour ce qui nous concerne nous
ne pensons pas que la transparence
augmente la confusion en fait nous nous
pouvons nous étions favorables dès le
début je pense pas qu'on ait fait
pression sur quiconque mais par contre
je pense qu'on était favorable dès le
début à ce que ces délibérations ce
public et qu'on pense que ça fait partie
d'un processus démocratique normal
sylvie vermeillet c'est juste une
question madame la ministre puisque vous
revendiquez la transparence et la vérité
sur la communication sur les masques
l'inutilité des masques à l'instant t et
vous vous appuyez sur la déclaration de
lomé mais dans ce cas pourquoi agnès
buzyn commandes des masques de 30
janvier voilà je peux merci
je pense que c'est tout simplement alors
je suis pas ministre de la santé à
l'époque mais dans ma compréhension
c'est que il est considéré que par
précaution il vaut mieux augmenter le
stock de masques par rapport à ce qu'il
est
à cette époque là et que donc il ya des
commandes qui sont réalisés en
l'occurrence ce sont de mémoire la
première commande c'est le 30 janvier
c'est des masques ffp2 de mémoire et
ensuite il a progressivement des
commandes de masques qui sont réalisés
et je me souviens aussi que la
consommation de masse qui remonte après
la première semaine de d'accélération de
la crise dans le grand est est très très
très très très largement supérieure à
tout ce qui était imaginable
je voudrais pas dire de bêtises sur les
chiffres mais on est dans un x 20 par
rapport à ce qu'on pouvait imaginer dans
une épidémie avec un virus aéroportée
notamment donc dont ça conduit à ce que
à partir du 30 janvier et à plusieurs
reprises et des commandes de masques
qu'ils soient faites dans un contexte
vous le rappelle il y avait une pénurie
mondiale de masques c'est là où il ya
des effectivement des controverses
il ya une incompréhension de la
population quand on lui dit d'un côté ce
sera un autre côté on en commander il
faut quand même on arrive quand même à
ce que la doctrine d'emploi et visait
les personnels soignants et visait à
assurer que à tout instant ils puissent
bénéficier de masques et d'équipements
de protection de manière plus générale
la question n'était base de n'était pas
d'avoir des masques pour la population
générale puisque nous n'avions pas à
cette époque-là d'indications et c'est
pour ça que je fais référence aux propos
de l'om est tenue le 30 mars qui disait
je le répète il n'y a pas de preuve de
l'utilité de l'utilisation du masque en
population générale
on est dans une situation on ne peut pas
dire que de temps en temps ça nous
intéresse que dit le ms et puis de temps
en temps on en fait fille catherine de
rush justement l'om et se disait aussi
faut tester tester tester et c'est une
déclaration qui est faite par le
directeur de l' oms le 16 mars et le 21
mars le ministre de la santé qui en
l'occurrence était olivier vers ans
indique que nous allons faire monter en
puissance la capacité de tests de
mémoire
alors nous allons pouvoir passer aux
questions des commissaires
damien regnard madame la ministre je
vous remercie vous vos propos liminaires
sur l'historique et le rôle du porte
parole du gouvernement
vous venez de prêter serment devant une
autre commission denquête de dire toute
la vérité
ma question est très simple à propos de
la santé la sécurité sanitaire le
gouvernement at il menti aux français
lors de la gestion de l'épidémie
notamment concernant la question des
masques leur port ainsi que la gestion
des stocks
sur une note plus légère jouait
d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui le port du
masque n'a plus aucun secret pour vous
et je m'en réjouis
merci
laurence cohen n'a oui merci monsieur le
président je pense qu'on ne peut pas
aborder la question de la communication
sens à la fois avoir en perspective nos
connaissances concernant évidemment la
pandémie mais en même temps la stratégie
adoptée par le parlement gouvernement
vous dites à un moment donné dans dans
votre propos liminaire ou dans les
réponses aux questions de des
rapporteurs vous dit
finalement concernant la pandémie le
sujet commence à monter dans l'actualité
mais est ce que c'est le rôle du
gouvernement est donc de vous en tant
que porte parole de suivre les
événements
est ce que vous n'avez pas un rôle
d'anticipation et c'est bien ce qu'on
reproche pour un certain nombre de
choses au gouvernement c'est à dire que
vous semblez dans vos propos madame la
ministre vous couler dans l'ambiance
c'est à dire aujourd'hui vous êtes
interrogée enfin hier plutôt vous étiez
interrogé par par les journalistes et
donc vous allez dans le sens de l'eau
vous êtes dans la communication est
effectivement vous nous informer de la
difficulté de résumer une pensée en
quelques tweets
mais on n'est pas là dessus on est sur
le rôle d'un gouvernement et de son
porte parole alors votre tâche est
lourde parce que quand on regarde
finalement ce qui s'est produit vous
avez aussi à gérer les couacs de vos
collègues pour lesquels vous êtes
solidaires parce que quand on regarde un
certain nombre de propos c'est assez
compliqué
de même quand on regarde il peut y avoir
une défiance au niveau de l'opinion
publique à juste titre quand on sait que
madame busin lance quand même une
information qui a de quoi troubler le le
18 mars au monde en disant qu'elle avait
prévenu le gouvernement dès janvier d'un
risque de contagion donc tous vos propos
à partir de là
sont obligatoirement remis en cause à la
lumière des manques des imprécisions
voire des mensonges si la vérité a été
caché et c'est là dessus qu'on vous
interroge madame un ministre c'est pas
pour analyser le passé et dire ah là là
là
le gouvernement a mal fait c'est sur le
rôle qui a été tenu par ce gouvernement
et sur ce qu'il faudrait faire dès
aujourd'hui pour corriger le tir donc ça
c'est ma première question
mama deuxième ma deuxième question c'est
concernant effectivement un moment où
l'opinion publique et troubles et à
juste titre a peur il n'y a pas de
médicaments il n'y a pas de vaccin il y
a une certaine cacophonie des
contradictions y compris dans le monde
médical et moi personnellement je ne
suis pas spécialement une scientifique
mais je n'ai rien ni en faveur du
professeur raoul ni en sa défaveur
parce qu'à un moment donné dans le
tâtonnement général il dit voilà moi je
fais ça bon après c'est monté en épingle
il ya le clivage ya le personnage etc
mais je le trouve que finalement le feu
qui a été portée contre lui à plus
aggraver les choses que bon à la limite
une possibilité de dialogue de deux
confrontations etc
je trouve que on a contribué aussi à
encore entraîné de la défiance puis
cette défiance
quand même de notre des françaises et
des français est de nous aussi en tant
que parlementaire elle est quand même
sur un fond de scandales qui ont eu lieu
au niveau sanitaire avec un certain
nombre de scandales je pense au médiator
et c'est une remise en cause très forte
des grands labos donc tout ça c'est le
terreau donc voila moi c'est là dessus
aussi que j'aimerais vous interroger et
monsieur sciamma sciamma pardon quand
vous vous dites c'est très intéressant
ce qu'on vous avait parlé par exemple de
l'idée de cette maison de la science et
des médias qui peut apparaître comme une
bonne idée
au demeurant mais effectivement qui en
fait
serait de nature à asseoir une certaine
comment dirais-je donner enfin une
science qui serait une science
officielle
je partage votre votre point de vue mais
je pense également que il ya une un
manque criant c'est pas seulement dans
le domaine des des journalistes qui
pourraient pour certains ne pas être
suffisamment formés et tout ça mais
c'est dans le monde de la recherche avec
avec finalement des fonds qui sont
attribués à la recherche qui sont
notoirement insuffisants et qui donc
entraîne aussi des difficultés dans ce
monde là est la difficulté pour les
chercheurs à la fois de pouvoir aller
jusqu'au bout de pouvoir communiquer de
pouvoir être indépendant et setra donc
il ya aussi ce climat là j'aimerais vous
entendre sur sur le sujet merci merci
victoire jasmin merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous avez
évoqué la transparence et
l'acculturation la connaissance
scientifique de la population
aviez vous une zone d'autonomie
suffisante qui vous permettait
d'effectuer des réajustements dans vos
propos aviez-vous la capacité d'utiliser
une sémantique qui permettrait de faire
de la pédagogie suffisamment de
pédagogie parce qu'on venait d'évoquer
le nombre d'apparitions publiques que
vous avez fait sur les médias donc vous
aviez quand même la possibilité même si
l'environnement depuis 1994 avait changé
concernant les missions des porte parole
du gouvernement
aviez vous un moment donné aux mis en
cause votre propre fonctionnement malgré
les éléments de langage que vous auriez
pu avoir un moment donné est ce que vous
aviez la capacité d'analysé entre les
réseaux sociaux les médias qui étaient
en continu vous allez vous l'avez évoqué
et votre propre fonctionnement au sein
du gouvernement monsieur sciemment vous
avez évoqué également des incohérences
des carences alors ces moments c'est moi
qui dit ça
parce qu'en fonction de ce que vous avez
dit vous avez à la limite accusé le
professeur raout de son apparition au de
ses apparitions sur les médias je ne
porte je ne suis pas son porte parole
je ne suis pas non plus là pour le
défendre mais il a eu une certaine
constance dans ses propos une certaine
cohérence et quel que soit ce qu'il a
dit moi je suis pas au niveau du
professeur il ya et raout
mais quand on a un président de la
république qui rend visite
un scientifique qui bien après avoir
commencé à tester tester tester parce
qu'il testait déjà quant au niveau du
gouvernement
les décisions ont débuté ont permis de
faire des tests et des tests qui n'était
pas forcément le fiable je n'en sais
rien parce que jusqu'à maintenant ne
sais pas trop donc la crédibilité qu'il
a eu et la constance de ses propos parce
que les médias parce que nous sommes
dans un contexte où la population est
confiné la population noire que la
télévision les réseaux sociaux parce que
pour sortir il faut justifier et la
plupart des gens qui sortaient c'était
pour aller s'acheter à boire et à manger
ou alors quand il était malade
évidemment il n'avait peut-être à aller
voir un médecin
mais est-ce que vous pensez que votre
jour là il vous propose d'investir ce
que vous avez dit parce que bon je ne
sais pas quels sont les journaux celui
qu'elle vous écumez parce que vous avez
pas les papiers que faisait ce qu est ce
que vous pensez que seul le professeur
il ya où tu étais sur les médias
beaucoup d'autres scientifiques étaient
sur les médias régulièrement des profils
des professeurs vais y avait un peu de
tout repos d'immunologie s'il y avait
les virologues y avait un peu de tout
mais tout le monde s'est focalisée sur
une personne et c'est ce qui a donné une
certaine crédibilité
il a une super proposition de valeur
comme je vous dis mais de chez moi je
vois à la télé et tout le monde parle et
ne parler que de lui
est-ce que c'était important de parler
autant de lui et de lui donner de lui
faire cette publicité
s'ils ne présentaient pas une certaine
menace
vaud de même vous aviez évoqué l'absence
de structures institutionnelles de
référence concernant les données
scientifiques et la communication de la
division communication officielle donc
vous avez parlé de maison des sciences
et plus c'est sans doute une très bonne
idée mais c'est quand même une idée qui
est anti démocratique dans le contenu
que vous voulez faire de cette structure
que vous suggérez
comment expliquer que vous êtes
journaliste scientifique que vous avez
un certain nombre d'éléments de piment
de référence et que vous ne faites pas
plutôt la suggestion qu'il y ait des
conférences de consensus et les
confrontations des confrontations entre
les stations les scientifiques toute
histoire vous proposé qu'il y ait des
étaient environ préenregistrés pour
ensuite transmettre éventuellement aux
médias si j'ai bien compris vos propos
alors est-ce que vous pensez que dans
une démocratie on peut gagner ce type de
propos je ne crois pas merci beaucoup
monsieur prison merci olivier paccaud
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le journaliste rené
paul savary a parlé de vérité il a
insisté sur ce mot et c'est
effectivement ce qui nous réunit la
volonté de trouver la vérité sur ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi cela n'a pas marché
entre guillemets pourquoi nous n'avons
pas su faire face
et pourquoi nous avons un bilan de 32
mille morts à ce jour
le but étant que cela ne se reproduise
pas se reproduise plus et donc nous
espérons que de cette commission et du
rapport qui en sortira des
préconisations pourront être suivies
pour savoir faire face ultérieurement au
niveau médical mais ce qui nous réunit
là aujourd'hui c'est la problématique de
la communication or dans cette crise et
se pense que c'est un cas unique dans
l'histoire épidémique la communication a
eu plus qu'un rôle clé puisque tout le
monde était confiné le monde entier
étaient confinés et donc le monde entier
hyper communiquer entre guillemets les
tous les hommes et toutes les femmes de
cette planète avaient les yeux rivés sur
leur écran c'était le seul moyen pour
eux d'être informé donc il faut
probablement en tirer des leçons au
niveau de la communication
nous avons connu un capharnaüm un
tsunami de communication ça déferlaient
ça ruisselle y en avait tout le temps et
effectivement il y avait beaucoup de
contradictions et quand communication
rime avec confusion
c'est l'effet totalement inverse de ce
qui était recherché alors j'ai une
question toute simple
il ya eu de très nombreux canaux de
communication le président de la
république
bien évidemment par la voix mais aussi
par l'image quand il est allé rendre
visite en matamore au professeur raoul
tu le premier ministre de nombreux
ministres
la porte parole du gouvernement pour
qu'une communication soit efficace en
temps de crise en temps de crise ne
faut-il pas qu'elle soit entre
guillemets coisy unique
n'aurait-il mieux pas vous value et là
je m'adresse peut-être plus à madame
ndiaye mais peut-être que monsieur
sciamma pourra nous éclairer qu'il n'y
ait qu'un seul communicants entre
guillemets et pourquoi pas le ministre
de la santé qui était a priori le plus
compétent pour communiquer le porte
parolat du gouvernement et je dis que ça
sans malice n'at-il pas nui à une bonne
compréhension de la problématique et une
bonne communication monsieur les
premières questions il y aura une
deuxième
salve derrière merci beaucoup monsieur
le président je vais peut-être d'abord
rebondir sur la question du sénateur
paco vous indiquez et vous avez raison
qu'il ya eu plusieurs canaux de
communication je voudrais d'abord
différents 6 qui a été la communication
institutionnelle de ce qu'a été la
communication politique la communication
politique étant celle portée par les
ministres membres du gouvernement la
communication institutionnelle
correspondant à ce que vous avez pu voir
la télé entendre à la radio voire sur
les réseaux sociaux les différents spots
du conçu par le sii j'ai notamment mais
également le web d'information
gouvernementale sur gouvernement.fr mais
également tout un tas d'actions par
exemple le fait d'avoir un chat bottes
qui enfin un chat qui soit pour qu'il
soit en langue des signes
le fait d'avoir des pages qui soit en
falcon en français facile à lire et à
comprendre
bref on a eu un foisonnement
effectivement en fonction d'une
stratégie qui étaient définis proposé
par le sg est validée par le premier
ministre en tout cas son cabinet pour ce
qui était de la communication
institutionnelle pour ce qui était de la
communication politique
cette crise a la particularité de ne
malheureusement pas avoir été qu'une
crise sanitaire
aurait-il été compréhensible que face à
la recrudescence de violences
intrafamiliales
les ministres en charge de ce sujet là
n'interviennent pas que ce soit le
ministre en charge de la protection de
l'enfance ou des de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes ou même le ministre
de l'intérieur dans une crise dans
laquelle où vous confiné votre
population
il me paraît légitime que le ministre de
l'intérieur qui est chargé de vérifier
de la bonne mise en oeuvre de ce
confinement d'un point de vue
sécuritaire
s'exprime pour donner des explications
sur la stratégie qui est la sienne
le fait que je pourrais vous donner
d'autres exemples
on a eu énormément de questionnement sur
l'annulation d'événements sportifs sur
la manière dont des sportifs de haut
niveau pouvait dans le cadre de la crise
est en préparation des échéances qui
sont importantes pour eux
puisse continuer à avoir leur
préparation physique le fait que la
ministre des sports s'exprime de manière
ciblée sur ces sujets là était
évidemment attendu
si je vous donne tous ces exemples c'est
pour vous dire que évidemment la
question aurait pu se poser que pour
avoir été conseiller ministériel dans un
autre quinquennat qui a vu se dérouler
malheureusement ces attentats de
sinistre mémoire
on avait à l'époque une communication
qui était resserrée autour du ministre
de la dga lien alors je vais dire il y
avait intérieur pm mini's
la justice et ministre des affaires
étrangères et mini désarmé mais on était
dans une crise qui était exclusivement
sécuritaire et donc les questionnements
qui pouvait y avoir été des
questionnements et uniquement
sécuritaire dans cette crise que j'ai
qualifiée de protéiforme dans mon propos
introductif on faisait face au fait que
les questions elle se pose est quasiment
sur la totalité des champs d'action
publique et que les ministres avaient à
coeur et je pense par exemple aux
ministres de bercy qui avait à coeur
d'apporter des réponses sur les sujets
de continuité de la vie économique
il ya des ministres que vous avez moins
jus parce qu'ils étaient moins en
première ligne et tous les
questionnements s'adresser - euh ça
c'est le premier sujet sur le moment
fort de communication qui amène beaucoup
de confusion parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui parlent
il y avait beaucoup de questions qui se
posaient mai
moi je crois que malheureusement ou
heureusement la société dans laquelle on
vit avec les exigences qui sont celles
des citoyens
[Musique]
en fait cette forme d'un faux démis en
quelque sorte est un corollaire de
l'évolution de nos démocraties avec la
colère avec lequel il va falloir faire
en quelque sorte et trouver sans doute
des moyens peut-être de rationaliser la
parole mais je me vois mal imposé à une
chaîne d'info de réduire son temps
consacrés au traitement de la crise du
coronavirus ni de lui imposer de bons
experts versus des experts qui serait
moins bon c'est pas possible
voilà je pense que des fois on dit mais
ils ont été aidés pour reprendre le
propos de catherine des roches qui était
un bon propos une note d'autocritique
non par rapport à cette communication
non ces voix là on demain à la même
situation ont fait pareil nous allons il
ya quelque chose qui avait effectivement
rien sur le sujet que poser le sénateur
paco je maintiens le fait que
[Musique]
que ça ne pouvait pas être communiste de
la santé parce qu'il y avait des impacts
qui était hors du champ sanitaire sur la
question de est ce que vous me posez la
sénatrice jasmin est ce que vous
disposiez d'une zone d'autonomie
suffisante pour faire évoluer les
éléments de langage qui était à ma
disposition pour vous expliquer les
choses au tout début de la crise donc ça
devait être à la dernière semaine de
janvier on a mis en place une task force
interministériel pour faire face au co
vide dans cette taskforce
interministériel le service
d'information du gouvernement avait
vocation à traiter des sujets liés à la
communication
le sg a été également associés à toutes
les cic synthèse et décision faite à la
cellule de crise interministérielle mon
propre cabinet y participaient et
pouvait donc en tant que de besoin à
l'appui
s'appuyant pardon sur les analyses de
l'état de l'opinion on avait également
des outils qui nous permettait de
connaître les questionnements principaux
qui était posé sur les réseaux sociaux
quels étaient les principales questions
qui étaient posées et donc d'ajuster la
communication institutionnelle voire le
cas échéant la communication politique
donc mon cabinet dans son interaction
avec la cellule de crise mais aussi avec
le cabinet du premier ministre a pu
avoir l'occasion d'ajuster les choses en
fonction de ce que nous faisions comme
analyse de des réseaux sociaux ou de
l'état de l'opinion ensuite pour
répondre aux sénateurs pardon à la
sénatrice cohen
vous m'interrogez sur le fait que que
j'ai dit que le sujet commencé à monter
dans l'actualité
je pense qu'il faut différencier deux
choses la première ça a été quelles ont
été les actions opérationnelles mises en
place par le gouvernement dès lors que
nous avons
eu l'émergence de cette nouvelle pomme
on bâtit en chine
j'ai eu l'occasion de rappeler un
certain nombre de dates qui apporte la
démonstration qu'il ya eu dès lors qu'il
ya eu détection de ces premiers cas de
pneumopathies à la fin de l'année 2019
la machine ministériel étatique s'est
mise en branle au fur et à mesure de
l'état des connaissances mais c'est
assez rare vous savez qu'on mette en
place des task force et interministériel
pour traiter d'un sujet ça a été le cas
dès la fin du mois de janvier le premier
ministre quand il fait des réunions
interministérielles à son niveau c'est
parce que les sujets sont des sujets
d'importance et la première qu'il fait
et je vous le rappelle le 26 janvier et
les premiers messages
la première réunion que le ministère de
la santé fait avec les professionnels de
santé par exemple leurs représentants
c'est le 6 février
donc en fait d'un point de vue
opérationnel on a eu une prise en compte
je crois extrêmement précoce de cette
crise
on a adapté notre organisation au fur et
à mesure de l'évolution de cette crise
ça c'est un sujet qui est à différencier
du questionnement qu'un journaliste va
avoir sur un plateau de télévision
je peux moi pour vous expliquer ce que
je faisais suscité une question ça
serait bien que tu m'interroge sur tel
ou tel sujet parce que pour nous c'est
un truc c'est quelque chose qui est
important mais le journaliste est
parfaitement libre ou pas de poser la
question et il n'était pas dans la tête
j'ai maté pas de questions de laurence
cohen la question de laurence cohen
parler sur le rôle d'anticipation que
semble-t-il voudrait justement cc alors
peut-être que la première emploi
participation à la réponse du
journalisme et d'anticipation la justice
du coup ma première partie de réponse
vous conviant j'imagine parce que j'ai
en tout cas j'ai apporté les éléments de
réponse que je pouvais vous apporter sur
non prise en compte précoce des éléments
liés à sa crise à travers les
différentes réunions que j'ai pu vous
citez témoignant ainsi d'une
attention particulière posées à ce sujet
là vont à la ministre ça ne ça ne ça ne
répond pas à en fait à ce que je vous ai
demandé mais je pense que vous n'irez
pas plus loin donc voilà vous avez
entendu ce que je vous ai posé comme
question j'entends votre réponse qui ne
me satisfait pas et qui ne va pas mon
avis satisfaire celles et ceux qu'ils
entendront l'audition et je leur en
laisse comme d'habitude je peux pas vous
apporter d'autres réponses qui qui qui
c'est une histoire de capitulation c'est
une histoire de deux limites de
l'exercice même sous serment
vous m'avez également interrogé madame
la sénatrice sur le sujet du professeur
ravoet il est à la tête de lit achu
méditerranée du j'imagine
et d'ailleurs je crois en avoir la
certitude que cette nomination elle se
fait en fonction de ses compétences
dans la situation qui était la nôtre où
nous recherchions ce que pouvait être
un traitement possible face aux
coronavirus il n'était pas question
d'écarter une solution vis-à-vis d'une
autre fusse-t-elle portée par quelqu'un
d'un peu iconoclaste donc le fait que le
président de la république fasse un
déplacement comme il l'a fait d'ailleurs
auprès d'autres scientifiques d'autres
chercheurs témoigne de la volonté qui
était la nôtre de ne négliger aucune
piste tout en ayant la les précautions
de
qualité du travail scientifique pour qu'
on puisse voir le cas échéant s'il y
avait un débouché possible
on a très vite autorisé dès lors que
professeur aof la demande et des essais
cliniques à marseille mais comme dans
d'autres hôpitaux ou villes de france
sur hydroxy chloroquine comme sur
d'autres molécules et à chaque fois
qu'il ya eu des doutes d'ailleurs voyez
bien qu'il ya eu des allers-retours y
compris de l' oms a pris l'étude du land
set on a suspendu relance est suspendu
et in fine est alors aujourd'hui je sais
pas quelle est la situation mais vous
voyez bien que on a aussi suivi ce qui
était le l'évolution des connaissances
scientifiques
à un moment donné vous évoquez le fait
qu'une défiance était installé sur les
sujets sanitaires
parce que on a eu par le passé des
scandales sanitaires je ne peux que
souscrire à ce que vous dites parce que
évidemment ça me une petit à petit la
confiance dans l'autorité
je crois aujourd'hui qu'on a des
institutions qui sont solides que le
fait que des commissions d'enquêté
telles que celles que vous portez ici
existe permet d'être dans cette
recherche de vérité de transparence pour
évidemment améliorer la manière dont
nous gérons ces crises et peut-être
lutter contre cette défiance le sénateur
renard m'interroger sur le sujet de
mensonges en général
que les choses soient très claires dès
lors que je suis dans cette commission
je dis la vérité je les jurés j'assume
les décisions politiques qui ont été les
nôtres dans le cadre de ce gouvernement
au moment où j'étais membre de ce
gouvernement
et je peux vous assurer que tout ce que
je vous ai dit correspond à l'état de
mes connaissances dans le cours de la
gestion de cette crise je voudrais quand
même rappeler sur la question de la
transparence est ce qu on a beaucoup
parlé du conseil scientifique etc
mais je vous invite vraiment à regarder
les choses dans leur intégralité
la france a été un des pays qui a fait
le plus d'efforts pour qu'on puisse
mesurer et dire clairement aux gens quel
était le nombre de décès à l'hôpital et
dans les ehpad
nous avons élaboré via le sujet des
espèces de tabac des espèces des
tableaux de bord qui permettait à tout
un chacun de manière transparente de
voir l'évolution de toute une série de
chiffres en matière sanitaire évidemment
en matière économique tableau qui
étaient publics on s'est d'ailleurs
inspiré pour le coup de publication qui
avaient été réalisés dans des médias à
l'international je me souviens que sur
la question des masques j'ai donné le
stock de masques chirurgicaux disponible
le 20 mars de mémoire dans une interview
matinale sur bfm tv donc ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que sur ces sujets de
transparence n'avons eu de cesse que de
d'apporter toutes les informations que
nous pouvions apporter au grand public
et je terminerai sur votre note d'humour
sur le port du masque parce qu'au fond
c'est quand même un sujet qui est
important notre pays avait pas forcément
la culture du masque au début de cette
crise culture qui a été acquise après
des années de pratique dans d'autres
pays vous le constatez sans doute comme
moi que dans la rue dans le métro
parfois le port du masque un peu bizarre
on enlève on met dans sa poche
on leur met on a un geste régulier parce
que le truc et manèges sûr que vous
portez des lunettes ça vous fait des
trucs de la buée donc vous essayé tant
bien que mal de le remettre alors
j'espère avoir eu les bons gestes ont
tous refusé moi mais vous n'avez pas les
bons gestes parce que le fait de croiser
oui ça sort ça sort latéralement donc ça
perd son efficacité non j'ai demandé
tous pareils on a tous de l'allumer
rassurez vous ces processus doivent
comprendre merci voilà ce que ce que je
voulais vous dire et c'est laid c'est
pour ça pour le coup je vous le dis
c'était une formule qui était maladroite
je reconnais complètement mon objectif à
ce moment là était de au fond de dire ce
que j'aurais peut-être dû dire
simplement que c'était on était à la
fois dans un moment où il y avait pas de
recommandations consensuelles sur le
port du masque en population générale
il y avait une recommandation de l' oms
notamment qui était de dire la priorité
doit aller au personnel soignant et
c'est comme ça qu'on a travaillé et dans
et deuxième chose nous avions par
ailleurs un pays où la culture du mas
n'existait pas c'est ce que j'essaie
d'exprimer gelé mal exprimé je sais que
s'il veut dire merci pour cette note
d'autocritique
c'est damien regnard c'est damien je
vous a écorché le je vous remercie pour
cette précision sur le port du masque
effectivement je pense que c'est
important de le rappeler régulièrement
et on voit des choses assez cocasse
quelquefois mais je crois qu'on a déjà
progressé un petit peu puisque vous
venait d'avouer de dire que votre
formulation était maladroit donc ça
prouve bien comme le demandent et madame
de roche et et notre président tout à
l'heure est ce qu'il ya un peu une
autocritique
est ce qu'on peut progresser est ce que
si la situation perdure est ce qu'on va
rester sur cette tête de ce ce type de
communication ou bien est ce que il y a
eu des erreurs de communication
voilà donc cesser c'est un peu
l'objectif de cette commission enquête
dont je vous remercie en tout cas de
votre réponse
merci à la polyphonie on doit la
recommencer parce que ça s'est
transformé en cacophonie
d'un côté on n'a pas de traitement et de
l'autre côté on compte tous les jours
les morts ça peut être des fois un peu
anxiogène on peut pas comprendre que la
population et des fois ils perdent un
petit peu sont son latin c'est la raison
pour laquelle madame on se permet
d'insister pour en cas de crise on est
on est pas là essayer de vous ennuyer
on essaye de faire derrière cette
commission est un certain nombre de
préconisations résidents le permettent
très rapidement deux roues on dire sinon
vous aurez l'occasion à construire des
sur la question des décès j'imagine que
vous vous souvenez de la polémique qui a
eu sur les décès en ehpad et le fait que
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
concrètement vous êtes le gouvernement
vous dit le fait de dire il n'y a pas de
traitement d'un montant on compte les
morts c'est anxiogène
si vous donnez pas le nombre de morts on
vous accuse de dissimuler la réalité de
la crise des injonctions sont parfois
contradictoires et de deux mots ont
choisi le monde et je crois que le
moindre est celui de la transparence
merci marie pierre de la gontrie c'est
un merci au pardon exact toutes mes
excuses monsieur sciamma n'a pas répondu
merci monsieur le président sur la
maison de la science et des médias je
crois qu'il ya eu un malentendu en fait
ce que j'ai exprimé à cet égard c'est
que c'était une idée à laquelle je me
reposais plutôt comme a par exemple
plutôt comme une tentative de faire une
science officielle sur la question des
financements de la recherche
j'approuve ce que vous avez dit madame
j'ai personnellement parlé un chercheur
qui est un des grands spécialistes
structurelle des couronnes un virus en
france le principal qui s'appelle bruno
canard et qui m'a raconté qu'il avait
demandé à plusieurs reprises des
financements en prévision d'une possible
pandémie pour étudier mieux les
coronavirus je signale en passant que
depuis le strass en 2002 il était
couramment admis dans les milieux
scientifiques que le risque pandémique
le plus grand était celui d'un virus
respiratoires probablement de cette
famille là c'est une hypothèse de
travail qui était répandu dans toutes
les communautés scientifiques et
d'autant qu'elle demers après donc
c'était quelque chose quand même qu'on
savait et est néanmoins ces travaux-là
sur les structures des courants d'un
virus non non non pas été financé ni par
la france ni par la commission
européenne qu'il avait demandé des
crédits et ce qui est amusant c'est que
une fois que mais c'est aussi un peu
désespérant une fois que la pandémie
était là on lui a dit vous avez toutes
les lignes de crédit que vous voulez
seulement ce qu'il aurait fallu c'était
comment ces dix ans avant former des
thésards travailler on ne peut pas
dépenser tout l'argent qu'on vous
propose quand on est scientifique dans
des contextes comme ça donc je pense
qu'il faut garder en tête ce problème et
la question de la préparation pandémique
qui reste une question parce que
finalement c'est pas parce que ce virus
là est apparue maintenant qu'il y en
aura pas d'autre
et peut-être éventuellement plus méchant
encore c'est quelque chose qui est
régulièrement discutée dans la
communauté scientifique et je voudrais
répondre encore sur ce que j'ai dit sur
le professeur raoul
j'entends bien sûr l'idée que c'était
peut-être pas opportun de lui donner
autant d'importance
je pense que et et qu'en répondant à ces
critiques finalement ça le valoriser je
pense quand même qu'il a joué un rôle
particulier dans ces crises je veux dire
i le professeur raoul c'est un peu celui
dont on ne dit pas le nom
on a ça dans dans certains films mais là
quand même on a eu un problème dès le
début avec des postures un peu d'oracle
je trouve et des postures d'oracle où il
a dit que c'était d'abord la fin de
partie pour le coc vide ensuite que
c'était juste qui est quelque chose qui
allait toucher de trois chinois ensuite
qui aurait pas de deuxième vague et donc
il ne s'est pas contenté de tester un
traitement sur lequel il avait eu une
intuition ça c'est parfaitement
respectable qu'un médecin dans un
contexte d'incertitude de croire en
traitement et le test je n'ai absolument
rien contre ça c'est l'ensemble de ses
positions et en particulier une de
celles qui a été le plus ravageuse qui a
été la taxe sur les conflits d'intérêt
vis-à-vis du corps médical attaque qui a
été reprise par le professeur theron
visant à dire en gros que tous ses
adversaires avec conflit d'intérêts avec
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
ça sur les réseaux sociaux on a vu ça a
eu un effet absolument ravageur et je me
permets de signaler ici que peut-être
c'est le signe qu'il faudrait que notre
institution médicale révise son rapport
aux laboratoires pharmaceutiques et se
pose cette question car ça la rend
extrêmement vulnérables à la critique
aujourd'hui en france un médecin
hospitalier qui veut aller à un congrès
à l'étranger il ne peut pratiquement pas
y aller si apam laboratoires
pharmaceutiques qui lui paye le billet
al'inverse les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques se bousculent pour lui
payer ce biais donc il n'y a aucun
problème
mais maintenant qu'on a pris l'habitude
de cela
notre corps médical est devenu très
vulnérable un certain nombre d' attaques
démagogiques donc peut-être qu'il faut
réfléchir à ce point et puis je pense
aussi que notre corps médical un
problème de mandarine à c'est à dire que
il ya une touchette non c'est pas du
tout nouveau nom mais nous l'avons payé
un peu cher
cette fois ci il ya eu une touche
habilités des sommets de l'institution
médicale et qui en plus semble
s'accompagner d'une conviction
d'infaillibilité et de l'habitude des
arguments d'autorité et mon dans le
fonctionnement ordinaire de la médecine
aux c'est peut-être pas tragique mais
l'âge là je pense a eu un coût de santé
publique important merci marie pierre de
la gontrie c'est merci monsieur le
président je voudrais revenir sur la
question de la confiance d'autant que
chacun ici a rappelé le rôle de cette
commission denquête mais nous savons que
désormais la question va se poser lors
ce qui arrivera le sujet du vaccin et
donc la confiance des français dans le
discours public est évidemment quelque
chose de toujours présents alors rappelé
que concernant les masques c'est de
cette séquence dont je parle et de leur
pénurie- le 26 janvier madame butin qui
ministre à l'époque dit qu'il n'ya pas
de pénurie le 4 mars
vous indiquez vous mais madame la
ministre on ne doit pas acheter de
masques nous avons donné des consignes
aux pharmacies le 17 mars olivier
verront alors ministre de la santé dit
nous avons assez de masques pour les
soignants et les malades alors qu'au
même moment les soignants qu'ils soient
chefs de service et donc on voyait sur
les plateaux mais aussi les
organisations professionnelles de
soignants pointe du doigt ce qu'ils
appellent un scandale sanitaire c'est à
dire l'absence de matériel et notamment
de masques pour les soignants et y
compris pour les soignants de ville
alors vous même
à l'issue du conseil des ministres du 17
mars vous indiquez les français ne
pourront pas acheter de masques dans les
pharmacies car ce n'est pas nécessaire
si l'on n'est pas malade
et donc je voudrais rapprocher
l'ensemble de ces propos de propos que
l'on vous a apprêté lors de votre prise
de fonction au cabinet du président de
la république et vous auriez dit
j'assume de mentir pour protéger le
président de la république
ma question est donc très simple
avez-vous menti pour protéger le
président de la république dans cette
période merci agnès prévu angèle
préville pardon merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
alors moi je vais revenir également sur
des questions que quand on a déjà évoqué
avec avec mes collègues et notamment
parce que je voudrais remettre quelque
part on a parlé beaucoup de dates
une date qui n'a pas été cité le
confinement à one et dans le hubei pour
trois grandes villes
c'est le 23 janvier c'est le 23 janvier
quand se souviennent bien de ça et donc
moi la question que je pose c'est est ce
que est ce que c'est quelque chose que
vous avez évoqué est ce que la prise de
conscience de la gravité pour le
gouvernement n'a pas été trop tardive
est-ce que l'acculturation scientifiques
dont vous parlez pour la population n'a
pas était également présente
de la part des membres du gouvernement
puisque le gouvernement avait en charge
la précaution de la population de la
protection de la population pardon et
donc par principe de précaution aurait
dû prendre toutes les mesures on avait
quand même l'exemple de ce qui se
passait en chine on avait l'exemple de
l'italie qui avait en quelque sorte
trois semaines d'avancé sur nous est ce
que quelque part il ya eu la question
que on n'ya pas cru
et puis ensuite la métaphore de la
guerre la communication n'aurait aurait
dû être moins chaotique et je rappelle
que chaotique le signification
scientifique de ce terme c'est un
désordre d'ordre supérieur donc la
communication a été chaotique
effectivement est ce qu'elle n'aurait
pas dû être plus sobre le corsetée et
plus bienveillante
parce que là aussi il ya quelque chose
vous avez évoqué alors le service
d'information du gouvernement avec des
analyses de
pignon mais évidemment si on ne pose pas
les bonnes questions on n'a pas
forcément certaines réponses si on ne
les pose pas est-ce que dans l'opinion
est ce que vous n'avez pas justement pas
voulu regarder ou pas eu l'idée de
regarder sur ce sentiment de distorsion
que ressentaient les français par
rapport à ce qu' ils voyaient eux et moi
j'en ai des retours sont mon département
de tout un chacun de ce qui se passait
en chine et de ce qui se faisait en
france comment vous n'avez pas vu qu'il
y avait une distorsion et que dans la
population finalement plein de vannes
une grande partie des français était
prête à apporter le masque et et assumer
tout ce genre de 2,2 de gestes de
protection pour se protéger de la
pandémie
voilà j'ai un peu le sentiment depuis le
début que dans votre communication vous
vous abritez beaucoup derrière on ne
savait pas mais on savait quand même un
certain nombre de choses et on n'a pas
découvert le virus en 2020 ce que c'est
qu'un virus déjà ce qu'une épidémie ce
qu'une pandémie et on avait quand même
l'exemple de la chine est bien
évidemment si un confinement commence un
23 janvier
on se doute bien on a tous vu les images
on se doute bien que ça avait commencé
un petit peu avant et qu'il y avait
effectivement à regarder ça de près et
je repose la question est ce que quelque
part le gouvernement n'y a pas cru
merci jean sol oui monsieur le président
madame la ministre
ne pensez vous pas que la stratégie
institutionnelle et politique en matière
de communication que vous avez mis en
place à plus inquiété que rassurer les
français et c'est l escaut paix avec un
certain nombre d'ordres et de contrôle
tenus bien souvent par différents
ministres notamment sur les thèmes
suivants épidémies ou pas les masques
notre collègue elle a parlé je vais pas
revenir dessus
les rassemblements l'école ou pas
l'hôpital est prêt mais en définitive
l'état savait très bien que l'hôpital
vivait depuis
vit depuis de nombreuses décennies une
pénurie notamment de moyens humains et
matériels ont en particulier monsieur
verra on m'a dit que c'était un bijou
ensuite le travail faut-il leur prendre
ou pas alors que dans le même temps le
slogan restez chez vous à étaient
affichés partout on nationalise ou pas
quant au secteur alimentaire dur at-il
panique de nos administrés ou pas que
feront les fournisseurs et puis vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure des décès on
entend clairement pas un qui a été aussi
de nature à perturber un bon nombres de
nos concitoyens je souhaiterais avoir
votre avis sur toutes ces questions je
vous remercie
je vous demande de répondre les uns et
les autres à une troisième salve de
questions qu'il commence merci beaucoup
monsieur le président je vais donc
répondre à la première question de
madame la sénatrice de la gontrie sur le
sujet de la confiance vous avez raison
de le souligner ça se posera
certainement au moment où je l'espère
nous trouverons un vaccin on a vu que
dans des crises précédentes la question
de la vaccination avait été extrêmement
difficile on me poser la question par
rapport à des propos qui ont été prêtés
je vais donc à nouveau ordonner les
circonstances dans lesquelles ces propos
qui ont été rapportés de manière
parcellaire m'ont été prêté il
s'agissait du moment de la campagne
présidentielle et législatives ça va
être assez triviale vous allez le voir
le président de la république
au futur président la république à
l'époque souhaitait faire une partie de
tennis un jour d'un week end électoral
sans meute de journalistes et
des journalistes se sont aperçus que il
avait quitté le lieu où il était pour
aller faire cette partie de tennis qui
était donc un instant privé qui qu'il
souhaitait privé et le journaliste un
journaliste en question m'interpelle
très très très très en colère
en me disant tu ne m'a pas donné la
possibilité d'accéder à ce moment très
important pour la vie politique
française de voir emmanuel macron faire
du tennis et ce à quoi je lui ai répondu
j'assume parfaitement de mentir quand il
s'agit de protéger un moment de vie
privée qui n'a rien à voir avec le
moment politique dans lequel nous sommes
c'est exactement les propos que j'ai
tenus je les maintiens
évidemment vous comprendrez bien que
vous le contexte dans lequel ils ont été
tenus ça n'avait rien à voir avec
d'éventuels enfin une éventuelle
décision de mentir sur les décisions que
pourrait prendre le gouvernement et donc
c'est évidemment la ligne que je me suis
fixé qui est une ligne attendue de la
tra des responsables politiques
normal en démocratie à tout le moins me
semble-t-il est donc au cours de la
crise du coronavirus g dans le cadre de
mes fonctions systématiquement relayer
les informations qui étaient à ma
disposition conformément au décret
d'attribution qui étaient les miens et
conformément aux informations dont je
disposais de la part de mes collègues du
gouvernement et aux décisions qui ont
été prises dont je le dis encore une
fois je suis parfaitement solidaire
madame la sénatrice préville j'espère ne
pas égorger votre nom vous me posez la
question de la prise de conscience par
le gouvernement de la gravité de cette
crise je veux à nouveau
dire nous inviter collectivement à faire
attention aux lecture rétrospective
notamment vis-à-vis d'un pays qui est la
chine et pour lequel peut-être certains
certaines informations ont pu nous
manquer à certains moments il ya eu des
éléments qui ont été communiqués très
facilement notamment sur la séquence adn
arn en l'occurrence du virus peut-être
d'autres l'ont été en tout état de cause
ce que je peux vous dire avec certitude
c'est que de manière très précoce dès
lors que nous avons eu une alerte qui
nous venaient sur une cette nouvelle ne
m'ont pas ti nous avons mis en oeuvre
les réunions au niveau ministériel
au niveau technique au niveau du premier
ministre pour anticiper cette crise à
tel point même vous savez réaliser une
évacuation de ressortissants français à
l'étranger
c'est un dispositif qu'on met en place
de manière relativement rare est
d'ailleurs très souvent dans des zones
où vous avez de la conflictuelle ite et
des guerres et en l'occurrence le choix
qui a été fait de rapatrier nos
compatriotes depuis ou cannes témoigne
évidemment de l'attention que nous
avions porté dès le début à cette crise
c'est une évacuation qui s'est faite qui
s'est organisée en quelques jours alors
que nous avions des difficultés
notamment pour les conjoints de français
qui n'étaient pas de nationalité
française sur place
donc je peux vous assurer de notre
pleine et entière mobilisation et de la
pleine conscience en fonction des
données dont nous disposions de la
nécessité d'agir
vous avez évoqué le sujet d'une com qui
n'étaient pas suffisamment bienveillante
si je comprends bien d'une communication
qui n'étaient pas suffisamment
bienveillante pardon d'accord d'une
communication qui n'étaient pas
suffisamment bienveillante
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
cette communication au fond sur la durée
de la crise elle a eu trois grandes
phases
on a eu une première phase entre eux
j'allais dire la fin du mois de janvier
et avant le confinement où l'objectif du
de la communication institutionnelle
était d'expliquer ce qui était le
coronavirus en fonction de son dont on
lève de ce qu'on avait comme information
est le leitmotiv c'était faire en sorte
que les français puissent adapter leurs
comportements pour pousser toute une
population à adapter ses comportements
c'est à dire à mettre de la distance
physique avec votre voisin à se laver
les mains très régulièrement ce qui
n'est pas une habitude qu'on a dans un
pays européen mois venant d'un pays
tropical de par ma naissance j'ai
toujours entendu mes parents me dire on
se lave les mains quand on rentre à la
maison je n'ai jamais entendu avant la
crise' coronavirus en france donc c'est
donc des changements de comportements
qui sont assez importants dans votre vie
de tous les jours et pour ça il fallait
que il ya une bonne raison qui motive le
changement de comportement
donc on a eu une communication qui
visait au fur et à mesure du temps à
dramatiser l'enjeu pour que chacun
comprenne bien que pour un bien-être
collectif il fallait une évolution
individuelles de ces comportements
ensuite la deuxième phase de la
communication gouvernementale
institutionnels a été le fameux restez
chez vous qui a été ensuite évoqué
l'idée étant de faire en sorte que pour
pouvoir freiner la propagation de
l'épidémie il fallait que les gens aient
le moins de contacts sociaux en fin de
compte des interactions physiques avec
d'autres personnes il fallait rester
chez soi et c'est là où effectivement
les choses se corsent
parce que vous dites aux gens restez
chez vous mais il faut qu'il ait une
continuité de la vie économique parce
que pour qu'ils restent chez eux
il faut et j'ai eu l'occasion de prendre
ce type d'exemple à plusieurs reprises
si vous voulez pouvoir boire une brique
de lait le matin il faut que y ait un
agriculteur qui traite des vaches qu'il
y ait des gens
qui transporte dans des camions ce lait
qu'ils aillent dans une usine
d'emballage pour qui un camion qui
existent faut qu'ils les garages qui
existe est institué des vous voyez bien
qu'il ya toute une chaîne qui se met en
place et qui nécessite pour que ce
restez chez vous soit effectif que des
gens malheureusement sorte pour pouvoir
assurer la chaîne logistique etc
et donc c'est là où on voit bien que
d'une intention qui est simple et d'un
message qui peut être très simple en
fait il en découle des nuances et que la
communication c'est là où ça devient
difficile c'est que vous devez expliquer
pourquoi il ya de la nuance et ça
évidemment voilà et après il ya une
troisième phase de la communication
gouvernementale
à partir du début du déconfinement qui a
été une phrase rester prudent on avait d
une ambiance médiatique qui consistait à
dire l'épidémie commence à décroître il
ya de moins en moins de quart de moins
en moins de décès et en même temps nous
étions extrêmement préoccupé par le fait
que le virus circule est toujours qu'ils
pouvaient circuler de manière de plus en
plus active et qu'il fallait que
l'acquis comportementale dans la
population française qui je crois il
faut le dire a été extrêmement
responsable et s'est saisi au moment du
confinement d'ailleurs comme duke
déconfinement de toutes les
préconisations qui était fait que ça
soit conservée et d'ailleurs on s'est
notamment inspiré de pour vous donner
les dessous de la faire des campagnes
qui ont été mises en place dans les
transports en commun attentif ensemble
attentif aux colis qui sont sans
surveillance notamment après les
différents attentat dans le rer
donc donc voilà on a eu une
communication qui a essayé d'être dans
comme communication institutionnelle qui
a essayé d'être dans la pédagogie pour
expliquer à chaque instant dans quelle
phase on était pourquoi est ce qu'on
faisait les choses
et qu'est ce qu'ils pouvaient pour
chacun concourir à un bien-être
collectif
tout ce que je peux te hais ce que j'ai
répondu et à tous peut-être le sénateur
le sénateur jean sol je vous ai répondu
du coup sûr le fait d'avoir une
communication plus inquiétante que
rassurante sur l'ordre contre horde
c'est que parfois il ya des injonctions
qui devait être contradictoire restez
chez vous mais certains doivent
travailler sur la question des
rassemblements des écoles etc
en fait on l'a bien vu que si je prends
précisément le sujet des écoles qu'on a
eu une évolution du consensus
scientifique c'est à dire qu'au départ
on a pensé que les enfants étaient en
quelque sorte des supers contaminateur
et que donc
il fallait faire en sorte qu'ils aillent
pas à l'école parce qu'ils étaient
susceptibles de transmettre la maladie
et puis ensuite la connaissance a évolué
donc nous on a dit bon on ferme les
écoles
et puis ensuite la connaissance a évolué
et il semblerait aujourd'hui je dis ça
tousse ou toute réserve parce que je
suis moins les choses que c'est un peu
l'un verse donc du coup les écoles
donc cet ordre contre ordre il résulte
aussi du fait que face à
l'inconnu vous découvrez des choses au
fur et à mesure et qu' il n'aurait pas
été et que forcément la décision
politique et ben il s'adapte y compris
pour des choses aussi lourde que ouvrir
ou fermer des écoles et donc voilà ce
que je pouvais vous répondre je voulais
juste vous demander avant éventuellement
la parole après je me suis fait de
commentaire particulier parce que les
questions s'adressait surtout madame la
ministre
à moins que j'ai raté quelque chose si
vous avez peut-être un avis à nous
formuler en ce qui concerne la campagne
de vaccination en espérant qu'elle ait
lieu un jour
est-ce que là dessus vous avez un oeil
particulier alors pour l'instant mon
inquiétude principale c'est le prix de
savoir si les vaccins qui seront mis sur
le marché seront correctement évalué est
ce que la procédure ne sera pas
précipitée par les pressions politiques
notamment des états unis voire par le
désir des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
d'être les premiers si toutefois les
choses semblent rassurantes là dessus je
pense qu'effectivement il y aura ensuite
un problème d'approvisionnement et aussi
de consentement vaccinale que nous
devrons gérer encore plus que dans les
épisodes précédents
je pense qu'il faudra particulièrement
soigné la communication à ce moment là
et bien choisir les publics cibles
puisqu'il sera possible de vacciner tout
le monde vous aurez un rôle à vous aurez
un rôle à jouer au niveau des médias
on essaiera de le tenir oui parce qu'on
voit bien aussi la complexité regarder
la vaccination grippale qui va commencer
et ça n'interpelle personne d'être tous
les ans et à 10000 morts en rapport avec
la grippe d'australie cette année la
vaccination grippale devra absolument
être réussie
et va jouer un rôle important et très
important merci mme angèle
oui voilà je voulais juste redemander de
3 mois + / l'infantilisation ressentie
par la population est ce que c'est une
quelque chose dont vous tenez compte ou
est-ce que ça n'existe pas pour vous
merci j'ai un sol moi je voudrais
revenir simplement madame la ministre
sans alourdir notre audition sur sur les
rassemblements comment expliquer aux
français et leur dire rester chez vous
alors qu'on autorise des matches
importants autour desquels il ya plus de
3000 supporters c'est tout ceci que je
voudrais mettre en évidence et émettre
cette communication face à ses
contradictions tout simplement merci
merci pardon excusez moi voyez je je
poursuis vous m'en excuser mais c'est
quand même me semble-t-il important on
voit qu'il ya une heure une reprise de
l'épidémie c'est une ondulation c'est
tout à fait légitimé par l'allemand on
explique qu'on va assouplir les mesures
dans les écoles donc les francis 10
attend ça c'est l'épidémie reprend mais
on aspire wee cc c'est une difficulté
extraordinaire nous le concevons bien
mais ça continue quoi allez-y rapidement
parce qu'on passe aux autres qu'ils
d'accord merci monsieur le président
pour rebondir sur ce que vous venez dire
alors je suis plus aujourd'hui en
responsabilité au gouvernement donc je
ne sais pas ce qui président au choix
qui sont faits mais je peux vous assurer
que ce type de sujet on l'a vécu à de
très nombreuses reprises et sur une
infinité de sujets différents sur la
question des transports en commun par
exemple versus le transport scolaire y
compris parfois avec des recommandations
qui était inapplicable c'est à dire
quand on vit dans un transport scolaire
dans la ruralité il faut conserver le
groupe place
conservez le groupe gascon disait il
faut que les enfants à l'intérieur des
classes quand on était au tout début du
déconfinement il faut que il circule
fait que le groupe classe soit conservée
comme ça quand on a un cluster qui se
déclare on reste à l'intérieur du groupe
sauf que ça fonctionne assez en tout cas
vous pouvez imaginer le faire
fonctionner quand vous êtes dans un
milieu urbain où les enfants vont
souvent à pied à l'école mais quand vous
êtes en milieu plus rural où il ya des
cars scolaires et du ram achats
scolaires et qu'on vous dit il faut
maintenir le groupe classe à l'intérieur
du bus scolaire
il ya une petite difficulté et en même
temps c'est un moment donné où les gens
devaient retourner au travail donc on
voit bien qu'à chaque instant et parfois
pour des petits détails vous avez
derrière le diable se cache dans les
détails beaucoup de difficultés et
parfois de contradictions pour rebondir
sur les deux questions sur la question
de l'infantilisation alors on a
effectivement regarder très précisément
les choses et moi ce que je retiens de
cette période là c'est que il y avait
une demande très forte d'être toujours
plus dur une aspiration en fait à ce que
les mails et les mesures prises soient
toujours plus dur est toujours plus
coercitives parce qu'en fait on avait en
comparaison internationale la france a
été l'un des pays où on avait le plus
fort taux d'inquiétude sur le
coronavirus non seulement sur la nature
de la maladie
si je la trappe je vais
avoir des séquelles très graves ou des
conséquences très graves et aussi sur sa
contagiosité donc on avait une
population qui était extrêmement
inquiète et les études qu'on avait nous
montrer qu'il y avait plus tôt
d'ailleurs quelque chose qui poussait à
ce qui est plus de dureté dans les
mesures qui étaient prises et donc c'est
aussi avec sac on a eu à faire ce sujet
de l'infantilisation a été une vraie
difficulté et en même temps quand vous
êtes dans un moment où devait imposer
des choses dans les changements
comportementaux comme vous devez imposer
le confinement
c'est de fait même presque
consubstantiellement une forme
d'infantilisation il ya d'autres pays
qui ont fait des choix de uniquement de
ne pas faire de confinement donc voila
et en même temps vous regarderez que sur
la question de l' isolement quand vous
êtes testé positivement
on n'est pas dans une injonction
on se base sur la responsabilité
individuelle et le fait que voilà sur
l'auto quarantaine donc je comprends ce
sujet d'infantilisation qui a été un
vrai problème avec lequel on a dû
construire la communication
institutionnelle mais je veux aussi
appeler votre attention sur le fait que
sur des tas de sujets il n'y a pas du
tout eu d'injonction du referme et je
prends en l'occurrence ce sujet là où il
ya eu aussi de la confiance qui a été
mise dans les français et dans leur
capacité à se saisir des choses sur la
question au rassemblement match je vais
plutôt vous renvoyer au ministre de la
santé qui a la compétence odette mans
plus grande que la mienne sur ces sujets
de stratégie aux sanitaires
merci alors maintenant michel monnier
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le président une
information que vous nous avez donné en
tout début de l'audition le président il
semblerait que l' agence santé publique
france n'est pas de service de
communication donc je voulais demander à
madame l'ex porte parole du gouvernement
quels étaient les liens que vous aviez
avec l' agence santé publique france est
ce que vous aviez une relation
privilégiée avec cet organisme
et puis à vous monsieur le président des
journalistes scientifiques
à votre avis est selon vous quelle est
la priorité des informations à faire
passer aujourd'hui compte tenu de ce que
nous savons de cette crise
merci muriel jourda merci monsieur le
président j'ai une question pour madame
l'ancien porte parole du gouvernement
vous avez indiqué que la communication
qui a été faite pendant cette crise
elle a été faite selon deux principes
qui était la pédagogie et la
transparence
il ya un troisième qui a été évoqué en
filigrane tout au long de cette audition
qui est quand même la cohérence qui
paraît importante aussi dans la
communication
je ne voudrais pas de questions sur les
masques on l'a déjà évoqué je me
contenterai juste de faire une
observation sur ce qui a été ressenti
probablement par une grande partie de la
population puisque nous avons les uns
les autres disques
et avec beaucoup de monde c'est tout
simplement lorsqu'il a été dit que le
masque n'était pas utile et vous l'avez
dit vous nous dites mais ce titre une
parole scientifique
la plupart des gens et vous n'y aurait
rien l'ont compris comme un mensonge
parce que ce qu'ils auraient voulu
entendre
est ce qui leur paraissait juste c'est
que nous n'avions pas assez de masques
pour la population et qu'il fallait les
réserver pour les soignants et cela la
population était capable de l'entendre
me semble-t-il
ceci tant ça n'est pas une question
parce que vous avez déjà répondu à cette
question je voulais plutôt m'attarder
sur la visite qui a été faite par le
président de la république au professeur
raoul le gouvernement est encore
aujourd'hui mais vous n'en est plus là
porte parole c'est beaucoup abriter si
je puis dire derrière les avis du
conseil scientifique pour prendre des
décisions
le professeur raoul faisait partie du
conseil scientifique
il l'a quittée fin mars d'une façon qui
a été assez médiatisé et quelques jours
après le président de la république est
venu lui rendre visite
alors le sentiment aussi général a été
que tout simplement le président de la
république en termes de pure
communication voulait tout simplement
s'approprie un peu de la popularité du
professeur rôle dont il faut dire par
parenthèse que s'il était populaire tout
simplement c'est parce qu'il a donné à
la population le sentiment qu'il faisait
son travail de médecin
c'est à dire qu'il cherchait un remède
et en plus pour le remède qu'il
préconisait était un médicament bien
connue des français qui donc de les
effrayer pas en tout cas ce sentiment a
été celui là que cette popularité le
président la république cherchait à se
l'approprier
vous nous indiquez pas du tout en
réalité le président de la république ne
voulait pas se priver d'une possibilité
d'un traitement qui existaient et on a
écarté à priori aucune des possibilités
qui avait été mise en avant par les
scientifiques
pensez-vous véritablement que c'était au
président de la république de venir voir
le professeur raoul pour ce faire et n'y
at il pas eu une incohérence de
communication a à la fois s'abriter
derrière conseil scientifique mais
finalement
briser celui qui en a claqué la porte
avec pertes et fracas et est-ce un
conseil de communication qui a été
donnée au président de la république qui
à mon sens n'a pas donné une grande
cohérence à la communication
gouvernementale
merci jocelyne guide s oui merci
président c'est vrai que le mot
transparence a été énormément évoqué
mais quand il ya trop de contradictions
même par le monde médical il ne faut pas
s'étonner qu'une méfiance mais aussi une
grande peur s'installe dans la
population un parfois ne vaut-il pas
mieux respirer profondément il ne rien
dire plutôt que de faire de la
communication alors qu'on ne sait pas
les différents intervenants
en tout cas dans cette salle on très
souvent employé on ne savait pas on ne
connaissait pas merci et peut-être une
des roches
oui juste une question je la pose
puisque je vais en a pour règle et
rapporteur de pas poser trop de
questions en débat mais comme elle n'a
pas été évoquée dans la suite des de
l'audition s'était concernant le service
d un fox coronavirus qui avait été
lancée par le service d'information du
gouvernement le 30 avril 2020 mais
finalement retiré quelques jours plus
tard parce que fortement critiqué par la
profession journalistique
alors ma question s'adresse plus aux
journalistes
à votre avis quelle est la bonne façon
lutter contre les filles nous dans une
kristen les terres comme celle ci est ce
que l'outil proposé par le gouvernement
étaient pertinents merci par ballon
difficilement sur les messages aux
prioritaire aujourd'hui je je je pense
qu'il faut vraiment attirer l'attention
de nos concitoyens sur le fait que le
virus est toujours là et qu'il est en
progression
je pense qu'il faut le faire d'une
manière qui ne soit pas dramatisante et
qu'il ne menace pas de se retrouver aux
urgences tous demain matin mais je pense
que c'est important de rester mobilisé
sur ce point concernant les fakes news
et la désinformation
bon ce service des enfants que ce
coronavirus enfin je n'étais pas pour
herri il apparaît c'est un petit peu
comme le gouvernement faisant le tri
entre les bons et les mauvais articles
dans les médias et ce ne pensais pas que
ce soit particulièrement opportun comme
stratégie est d'ailleurs le gouvernement
a compris très rapidement et à
abandonner ce projet sur l'effet que
news il ya eu un rapport en mars 2018
commandé par la commission européenne un
groupe d'experts qui s'appelle leurs
élèves à l'export regroupe en fait news
online désinformation qui est vraiment
un peu une référence en ces matières
ce qu'il faut souligner c'est c'est
qu'il ya pas de solution simple et que
la censure dans est pas une il faut
quand même respecter la liberté de
parole mais en même temps nous avons un
vrai énorme problème je me souviens que
deux ou trois des groupes complotistes
les principaux je crois que c'était au
début avril il y avait une étude qui
avait été fait selon laquelle leur poste
sur internet représentait quatre fois le
volume de transmission des postes des
six principaux médias français
donc c'est une très grosse vague et il
ya une étude de style ce qui a montré
que les post mensonges et circule plus
vite plus loin et touche plus de gens
que les postes véridique sur les réseaux
sociaux
en fait l'explication est très simple
c'est qu'ils apparaissent comme nouveau
et surprenant
et dans ce qui est nouveau et surprenant
il ya une majorité de choses fausses
c'est comme ça donc moi je pense que
face aux flics news une des choses
importantes qui était dans ce rapport
c'était de donner le statut d'éditeur ou
plateforme internet mais ça c'est un
combat juridique très long complexe qui
doit se mener à l'échelle européenne qui
posent des problèmes géopolitiques mais
rendre les plates formes responsable de
ce qu'elle publie et on en prend le
chemin très doucement ça c'est
absolument essentiel
l'autre chose c'est qu'il faut
construire en face de cette masse de
désinformation il faut qu'ils aient des
médias plurielle qui travaillent bien
qu'ils aient le temps de travailler qui
sauve une situation économique pas trop
désastreuse et qu'ils puissent offrir un
pôle de référence dans leur diversité
en face de la désinformation et ça ça
peut en partie résulté d'actions
publiques de soutien à la presse dans
travail une concentration excessive de
la presse comme telles celles que nous
voyons
aujourd'hui je pense que des médias en
bonne santé
prosper et qui travaille bien ça fait
partie d'une démocratie au même titre
que ce lieu c'est un coût certes mais
c'est important que la puissance
publique s'efforce de maintenir sa phase
avec des informations
merci merci monsieur le président
d'abord peut-être pour répondre à madame
la sénatrice e meunier qui évoquait le
fait qu'il n'y avait pas de service
pardon de communication spf et me poser
la question du lien du coup entre le
porte parolat du gouvernement et santé
publique france au moment de en tout cas
pour ce qui était le cas pour moi
concernant la gestion de cette crise sur
les informations
[Musique]
et qu'il fallait faire circuler et sur
la construction des éléments de langage
à destination de nos écosystèmes
on s'est appuyé pour ce qui était de mon
cabinet sur le centre de crise de
communication de crise du ministère de
la santé avec une cellule qui était
constitué de fonctionnaires du ministère
de la santé avec un directeur de la
communication en l'occurrence une
directrice de la communication du centre
de crise et c'est avec eux qu'on avait
des interactions parce que l'idée était
pour nous de pas démultiplier les portes
d'entrée dans toutes les agences
sanitaires divers et variés au risque de
produire de la confusion donc on avait
en fait un interlocuteur qui permettait
de valider les messages d'un point de
vue j'allais dire scientifique et
sanitaires cet interlocuteur c'était
était intégré au centre de crise du
ministère de la santé et permettez nous
ensuite au niveau du porte parolat de
nous assurer qu'on ne faisait pas de
bêtises par rapport à la situation
sanitaire dont c'est comme ça que les
liens se sont construits et évidemment
nous avions également un travail qui
incluait le service d'information du
gouvernement puisque vous le savez il ya
eu une page de foire aux questions sur
ce fameux gouvernement.fr et le scg
faisait la vérification des informations
auprès des ministères compétents
informations sanitaires à la santé
informations économiques à bercy et
ainsi de suite pour s'assurer qu'ensuite
tout ce qui y venaient et évidemment il
y avait plusieurs niveaux de validation
pour que on
on n'est pas de choses mensongères ou
fausses même sans avoir sans l'avoir
voulu qu'ils puissent être dit
ensuite concernant
la question de la cohérence qui était
posée par madame la sénatrice jourda
c'est évidemment un moment et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire au cours de cette
audition qui est extrêmement difficile
parce que vous avez des dans la
stratégie est donc dans la communication
autour de ces stratégies des choses qui
pouvait paraître antinomique est
typiquement restez chez vous mais pour
certains aller travailler a fait partie
des choses qui étaient antinomiques mais
pourtant qui se justifiait tout les deux
donc ça a été je crois une des vraies
difficultés parce qu'il fallait avoir
une cohérence dans le temps et une
cohérence à un instant t
donc inspecté c'était rester chez vous
mais en même temps certains doivent
travailler et cohérence dans le temps
c'est que en fonction
on s'est adapté à 7
on s'est adapté aux connaissances qu'on
avait y compris je constate encore
récemment que on découvre maintenant que
la transmission du coronavirus se fait
pas que parler boutelet tu es tu pars de
manière manu portée mais que
manifestement elle peut se faire aussi
par aérosol donc on voit bien que ça ça
forcément des implications sur la
manière dont on gère les gestes
barrières et la protection et la
prévention vis-à-vis de cette maladie et
les gens pourront se dire à bon droit
mais il ya deux mois il ya trois mois
c'était parce qu'on m'avait expliqué
c'est à nous aussi d'avoir cet effort de
pédagogie en espérant être compris sur
l'évolution de la connaissance
scientifique vous m'aviez également
interrogé madame la sénatrice sur le
fait que le président la république est
rendu visite au professeur raoul
souhaitant ainsi s'approprier sa
popularité alors je suis assez convaincu
de par mon métier en tant que
communicante que on arrive rarement à
s'approprier la popularité des autres
c'est un chemin qui marche jamais donc
si on m'avait interrogé
dans ce but là je l'aurais dit mais en
l'occurrence je n'étais plus conseillère
du président de la république mais
j'étais une de ses ministres
je crois que dans ce moment là il a
simplement souhaité comprendre tous les
points de vue et montrer que nous
n'étions pas un camp contre un autre
mais qu' il y avait des personnalités
scientifiques qui proposait des
solutions qu'on leur donnait les moyens
pour pouvoir tester ses solutions et
sans exclusive et qu'ensuite à la
science nous dire est ce qu'il fallait
en retenir sur la question qui m'a été
posée parfois faute il ne vaut-il pas
mieux se taire plutôt que de parler
moi je considère d'abord que quand vous
êtes dans une situation de très forte
pression médiatique
quel est le choix qu'on doit faire entre
être là dans un média pour dire ça je
sais pas ou ne pas y être et avoir un
média qui dit le gouvernement se cache
et refusent de venir parler devant les
français face à la plus grande crise
sanitaire que nous ayons connue de
manière contemporaine
mon choix était vite fait et j'ai
considéré qu'il valait mieux parfois
aller dire ce qu'on savait ce qu'on ne
savait pas le premier ministre
d'ailleurs l'a fait à deux plusieurs
reprises au cours de ces allocutions
télévisées ou de saisine interview parce
que malheureusement la nature ayant
horreur du vide
vous pouvez vous retrouver dans une
situation où les gens qui sont les
complotistes ceux qui développent des
faits qui nous remplissent l'espace qui
est ainsi laissé à leur portée et pour
finir madame la sénatrice de roche je
voudrais peut-être apporter un éclairage
sur le sujet des faits que news delà de
la désinformation
d'abord c'est une crise plus que ce que
j'ai jamais connu de d'un point de vue
professionnel qui a été caractérisée par
une inflation absolument j'emploie un
mot à dessein qui est dantesque des
fausses informations dont un certain
nombre et j'allais même dire ah non non
négligeable était à caractère médical
donc on avait des fausses informations
qui circulaient sur comment se prévenir
du coronavirus quel traitement et je
n'ai même pas dedans l'hydroxyde
chloroquine mais on avait des trucs
absolument dingue autour de jets d'eau
de javel frottez-vous le corps avec des
racines de gingembre ou dieu seul sait
quoi
et don de connaissance de la maladie
donc on était face à de ce point de vue
là ce qu'on a identifié comme un vrai
risque de santé publique
il fallait que on puisse apporter des
informations d'où ce hub de
d'information c'est on a même mis en
place sur des messageries par exemple
whatsapp des messageries de chat bottes
qui permettait de poser des questions et
d'avoir des réponses automatiques sur
des choses un peu un peu claires ensuite
on a mené un gros travail
constatant cela avec les plateformes de
réseaux sociaux je les ai réunis alors
je suis plus à combien de reprises chose
doit être trois ou quatre avec
le ministre en charge de la protection
de l'enfance méninges du numérique
protection de l'enfance parce que les
jeunes sont très utilisateurs de ces
réseaux de ses plateformes et on a été
dans un travail qui a été très difficile
parce que vous connaissez la position
qu'ils ont notamment sur le fait d'être
éditeur mais on a plutôt eu un travail
en bonne intelligence
y compris parce qu'ils avaient eu eux
mêmes de manière très récente en tout
cas pour la france à gérer la diffusion
de l'information sur les incendies de
lubrizol où il y avait eu des vidéos
notamment la vidéo avec de l'eau noire
qui coule et c'est à qui avait provoqué
un très fort émoi alors qu'elles ne
correspondaient pas à la réalité donc
vous avez quand même une prise de
conscience je ne dis pas que à cause de
lubrizol mais qui s'étaient forgés avec
le temps qu'eux ils avaient une
responsabilité particulière à jouer et
donc on a eu avec eux un travail et en
particulier les travail du et sujets
dont deux là pour donner une impulsion
politique sur la manière d'identifier
des sources fiables
autrement dit le dernier décompte
complotistes est pas aussi fiable que l'
oms voyez pour qu'ils puissent et aussi
pour mettre en avant des messages de
santé publique relatif aux coronavirus
et pour finir sur la polémique sur la
page du gouvernement je dois vous avouer
que
pour le coup ça a été une maladresse au
sens où le but que nous recherchions
était compte tenu du flot de fausses
informations auxquelles on était
confronté de donner le maximum
d'endroits pour les français où ils
pouvaient trouver une information fiable
sur et vérifier que la page du
gouvernement consacrée au corona virus
recevait plus de 750 mille visiteurs
uniques jours donc c'était un des
majeurs de recherche de l'information et
que on a essayé de faire de 10 mètres un
endroit où les gens qui allaient pas
forcément regarder sur chaque site de
journaux vous pouvez retrouver ce qu'on
appelle le demon king d'une information
c'est à dire la vérification de cette
information pour savoir si elle est
exacte ou si elle est inexact et on
l'avait fait très attention à ce que le
sjg qui était porteur de ce projet est
fait très attention à ce que on n'avait
jamais dans la zone grise typiquement on
n'allait pas sur l'idh roxy chloroquine
parce que il n'y avait pas au fond de
vérité qui était admis sur les docks si
chloroquine mais sur faut-il ingérer de
l'eau de javel pour nettoyer l'intérieur
ça on savait à peu près que il y avait
été pourtant cette vidéo là elle a fait
un bref et donc notre objectif était pas
du tout de trier le bon journaliste du
mauvais journalistes c'est une évidence
ni de trier le bon média du mauvais
médias à la bonne information de la
mauvaise information dès lors qu'il
s'agissait d'une opinion mais quand on
avait deux du factuel
on pouvait on est allé chercher
exclusivement plutôt des fins de mémoire
des articles qui venait des facs shaker
et pour une pour une information donnée
on faisait
le site enfin la page faisait référence
à plusieurs facteurs différents pour
justement une dans la pluralité de toute
évidence force est de reconnaître que
cette initiative n'a pas été comprise et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le service
d'information du gouvernement a fait le
choix de retirer cette page
parce que quand vous n'êtes pas compris
à ce point c'est que manifestement soit
vous avez mal préparé les choses avec
les acteurs en question soit vous avez
eur t il quelque chose de très profond
chez eux donc cette page
elle a été retirée moi je voulais
profiter de cette audition vraiment pour
dire quel était notre intention est que
ce n'était pas une intention qui étaient
malveillantes à l'égard des médias
c'était face à cette déferlante de
fausses informations
et du coup on a beaucoup posé les
facteurs d'amélioration
je crois vraiment que dans les
démocraties qui sont les nôtres aussi
parce que dans les faits que news qu'on
a eues à gérer il y avait défectueuse à
caractère médical mais yao bo xi skies
la zone grise de l'afrique news des
jugements sur le haut des informations
sur la gestion de la crise par les
différents gouvernements notamment en
europe et donc on voyait bien que il y
avait quelque part comment dire quelque
chose qui tendait à dire
il ya certaines type de démocratie qui
n'ont pas réussi d'autres qui ont mieux
réussi dans la gestion de la crise c'est
d'ailleurs ce à la zone grise en tout
cas moi ce dont je suis convaincu c'est
que ce sujet de la fausse information
est un sujet majeur qui peut vraiment
miner les fondements de notre démocratie
parce que quand les citoyens ne sont pas
éclairées par des informations qu'ils
sont portés par des journalistes qui eux
mêmes sont protégés par une déontologie
il ya de très fort risque de voir ce
serait se répandre des des sentiments ou
des informations qui sont vraiment de
nature à mettre en danger notre
démocratie et pour moi c'est sans doute
l'un des sujets sur lequel il faut
travailler dans la gestion des crises à
venir
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci notre hymne des roches
oui sur ce que vous venez de dire sur
cette zone grise c'est là où en frise on
peut friser la censure parce que si on
ne peut rien dire ceux des gestions
c'est ça qu'a pu faire que ont en effet
on dise que boire de l'eau de javel
n'est pas forcément très indiquée dans
l'épidémie on peut l'entendre sur le
reste c'est là où il ya quand même une
zone très fragile
oui bien sûr c'est pour ça que je vous
précise bien que cette page des infos du
gouvernement était vraiment
exclusivement consacrée à des choses
aussi évidente que le jval mai
vous vous doutiez pas que ça allait être
incompris position en fait pour vous
dire vraiment les choses il y avait eu
donc le sii j'ai été en contact avec les
responsables de rubrique désintox
désintox fait que nous de différents
médias les avaient informés de
du fait que cette page allait advenir
ils n'ont pas fait ce que sans doute si
ça avait été ils n'ont pas fait appel
aux patrons de rédaction et donc parfois
quand on est dans sa rubrique tous les
moyens qu'on a de pouvoir démultiplier
les zones où on peut trouver votre des
bonnes king et le lièvre que vous avez
levé sur une fée qui nous c'est plutôt
positif
alors que
tel ou tel chef de rédac aurait-elle dit
attendez il ya un problème donc en tout
cas dans la chronologie il ya eu une
information qui a été envoyé aux médias
peut-être pas aux bonnes personnes et au
bon niveau dans les médias de la part du
sg pour prévenir de cette page là il n'y
a pas eu de retour négatif donc ils ont
pas pensé
les frontières du sg qu'il pouvait y
avoir un sujet c'est quand plus tard
mais plusieurs jours plus tard les
choses ont ont été je parle monte en
épingle que que de fait
des médias ont dit on n'est pas content
que nous on a essayé d'expliquer et que
l'un dans l'autre on a compris que cette
incompréhension là était pas
vous pouvez pas la résoudre à ce sujet
monsieur siaap ma avant de passer la
parole à je pense que face aux aux
fausses nouvelles sur internet c'est
important d'être dans la réaction rapide
et effectivement le travail de
surveiller ce qui circule sur les
réseaux de voir si quelque chose est en
train de gonfler et d'identifier
finalement à quoi il faut répondre
rapidement dans l'instant je pense que
ça c'est utile et c'est quelque chose
qui est un peu invisible en fait parce
que on ne voit pas forcément quand on a
apporté la réponse
l'info se propage quand même mais moins
vite et avec moins de force de
percussion en quelque sorte
par contre je pense que c'était
maladroit de l'organiser avec
l'étiquette du gouvernement et je pense
que ce type de choses pourraient
peut-être gagné à être organisé plus tôt
par un partenaire académique soit une
université soit un institut je sais pas
à l'institut pasteur
enfin il faut penser à comment on
étiquette ce type de service parce qu'il
faut le faire mais il faut pas que y ait
de risque d'apparaître comme voulant
récupérer l'information
merci d'accord muriel jourda
oui je crois que vous n'avez pas répondu
à ma question madame la ministre et
est-ce cohérent en terme de
communication de la part du président de
la république de se rendre chez le
professeur raoul et de se montrer avec
le professeur raoul alors qu'il venait
de quitter le conseil scientifique
derrière les avis duquel le gouvernement
n'a cessé de s'abriter
je pensais avoir été clair dans les
intentions du président de la république
qui par ailleurs
de manière pour le coup très cohérente a
aussi rencontré d'autres scientifiques
étaient moins médiatique mais
et pas tellement du fait du président de
voix là et il a été de mémoire
rencontrer des équipes de recherche à la
pitié salpêtrière je crois il l'a été je
crois aussi le pasteur mais votre
réponse est très factuelle mais la
question de mariage ou là une question
d'analyser ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui devant cette commission qui
avait une cohérence où il y avait une
incohérence
d'abord il ne m'appartient pas parce que
ce n'était pas mon rôle de juger de la
stratégie de communication du mené par
l'époque et aujourd'hui ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que la cohérence qui
m'apparaît et que dans un moment où vous
avez des opinions différentes qui
s'expriment
le fait que le président la république
apporte la démonstration que l'autorité
politique n'est pas dans le choix d'un
camp contre un autre parmi les
scientifiques mais va regarder chaque
chacun chacune des possibilités
quitte à ce que ensuite ses possibilités
soit refermée mais pour moi il est
cohérent de montrer que il ya un corps
scientifique et médicale qui se
mobilisent avec des opinions divergentes
et qui ensuite bas au fond les essais
cliniques permettront d'un pensez pas
que ça brouille le message en son nom 80
des roches la question de muriel jourda
elle est sûre conseil scientifique était
celui qui nous était cité en permanence
par le premier ministre par président la
république ou par d'autres ministres
comme la référence de conseil et la
question d'une journée celle ci la
mesure le professeur raoul s'était
éloigné du conseil scientifique est ce
que le fait d'aller 20 noeuds fragilisé
par le conseil scientifique un don je
croyais la question c'est clair si je
crois vraiment pas pour le excuses et de
clarté dans son intervention c'est bien
connu je suis les yeux
je présente mes excuses si vous l'avez
interprété de cette manière ce que je
voulais dire par là c'était que en fait
d'abord il faut avoir en tête que dans
le conseil scientifique vous aviez des
personnalités qui étaient d'éminents
représentants de leur discipline mais
qu'ils n'étaient pas les seuls
représentants de cette discipline là et
que donc quand le président s'est
déplacé notamment dans des hôpitaux
auprès de laboratoires de recherche
n'est pas aller que dans les
laboratoires dont étaient issues des
gens du conseil scientifique donc il y
avait pour moi pas d'incohérence à ce
qu' il puisse
voir des gens prendre des conseils de
gens qui n'étaient pas exclusivement
donc on sait scientifique je vous
rappelle notamment qu'il avait contacté
le médecin un des médecins qui est
français how can pour avoir une idée de
comment est-ce que lui qui avait été au
coeur de la toute première vague avait
géré un certain nombre de choses et
c'est pas pour autant que tout a été
suivie mais c'étaient des éclairages qui
permettait de dd a forgé la décision
politique merci pas d'autres remarques
particulières donc vous le souhaitiez
très bien écoutez je je je vous remercie
on met donc fin à cette audition
rendez-vous pour nos commissaires à
15h15 heure un merci